If you let D hit, you wouldn't have this >> His entire
worldview is repulsive to me. He's a bad person. He's a bad father.
I mean, objectively a bad father. His son is now a neo-Nazi.
>> Well, his son, why didn't you just let Desi you if you
if you let Desi you, he wouldn't even be a problem anymore. >> And
it's directly a consequence of like him not paying him any attention
whatsoever. He got ritualistically humiliated on the timeline.
Uh, you know, flew too close to the sun and he hasn't really
recovered since then.
>> I think Assan react Yeah, son reacted to this at the
end of his stream last night. [music] Let's see. >> There's
a whole different world out >> Assassan is worse than Jeffrey
Epstein. That's what it shows. >> Jeffrey Epste I will
say I will say that's a crazy line to bring it on. That that
makes it sound like Pisco is saying this is his position. WHAT
IS JEFFREY did when you said I will vote for Epste [__]
JD Vance. Tell me what is Jeffrey Epstein's policy platform.
>> Dude, [laughter] you don't need to know Jeffrey Epste.
Here's what I know about him. You said abortion. You don't need
voted for him over JD Vance. >> Here is what I know that.
>> Here is what I know about Hassan. He romanticizes, lionizes,
and idolizes Vladimir Lenin. Why would you vote for her for >> harm
reduction? Hassan would be better than JD Vance. That's why you
would vote for Epstein over JD Vance. Wait, that's why you would
vote for Epstein. So, so then say it, Hutch say. >> Hutch
said he would rather vote for Jeffrey Epste over me because I
lion eyes the lion himself, Vladimir Ilage
Yeah, Lenin was awesome. What the What's his problem? He said
you're worse than Trump. Yeah, Destiny has said that. Assan or
Trump? Who you voting for if you had to pick? Trump is at least
some vague notion of supporting America, however misguided it
is. If he destroys a country, it'd be a byproduct of his stupidity
and nar with Assan. It would be ideological by design. He supports
foreign terrorist groups, despite despises US allies, supports
historical revisionism to pay US adversaries in a better light.
Has admitted that he would ban opposing political parties in
the United States and would lock his enemies forever in reeducation
camps if they didn't agree with his political ideology.
All of these people, if you were to ask them like, wouldn't you
put some of the fascists in re-education camps, would say yes
at this point. By the way,
what is this? Alleged
Destiny says he's jealous of >> saying he's going to
>> I don't just to be clear. Um
I don't think they're true truly allegations that Destiny
I'll I'll just make this clear because some people are going
to say I'm really bad faith.
I don't think Destiny's a rapist. I've never like e- rapist is
he doesn't care about consent but I don't think Destiny is ever
going to physically violate somebody. One I think he lacks the
muscle mass to overpower most women so just never happening.
Okay. And two I just don't think that's a part of his like encoding.
But um and the thing is like again colloquially he basically
likes violating boundaries. He likes um he likes being like there's
something here where he he like fetishizes
boundary violation in a way. There's something to that, right?
Where like he likes he likes pushing the the line really badly
and that applies to girls as well. And he he had this this person
and was told they were 17 and he didn't get rid of it. So he
retained child porn somebody but I don't think that's because
they looked like a kid. Okay.
M a feopile. Yeah, a fe a feile. Okay, so I'm just that's the
one of the times. That's the only time during this I'm going
to slow down and say, hey, that's the actual truth here. Okay,
so is what's actually happening. Okay,
the game is to do the most is doing the most psychotic things
possible while maintaining plausible deniability.
I do believe that's what it is, right?
Board a flotilla to Cuba. And a lot of you guys were saying there's
no shot that he does that. He absolutely will do that. Flotillas
are like the best. They're like the best um pointless PR that
you can ever do. That's probably the most Turkish thing he's
ever done. Um because flotillas love to go from Turkey to to
Israel to stir some [__] up. What you do is you call
yourself a humanitarian aid flotilla.
Do they go from Turkey or do they go from Cypress or is he saying
Cypress is Turkey? Which I usually don't disagree with that much,
right? Isn't Isn't Drew Pavlu Cyprian?
He tries to claim that he's like Greek, but he's actually totally
Turkish. He's got like a ton of Turkish DNA. >> Isn't that
your ships or all of them are empty? You might have supplies
in a single boat. And then all of you are like media trained
and press ready. You're live streaming and broadcasting. You
know that what you're doing is probably illegal or is going to
get intercept. It's basically like the grown-up version of um
of when Lauren Southern was with um >> Yeah. far superior
is my method which is watching Hassan [__] clips
while playing Arc Raiders and Malding. Also, did you guys notice
he did a dog whistle at the behest of Israel there when he was
like Turkish? Yeah, I can't believe I can't Oh, sorry. I can't
believe Destiny is snarking on Flutellis. I just I don't get
it. I literally don't get it at all.
Oh, did he bring up Lauren Southern? Oh, Lauren Southern does
come up today when we get to the lonerbox stuff, which I'm truly
regretting. Okay, I'm truly regretting it. I'm going to say I
feel like I'm going to say some stuff when I listen to this Loner
Box coverage.
I
I might have to join up in VC. I don't know if Queen's around,
but once I get to the Loner Box stuff, I'm probably going to
have to join up in VC. I I listened I when I first woke up somebody
sent me a link to the lonerbox stuff and I'm like bro I
I personally think and I know people would say the same thing
to me and maybe I'm I'm even trying to go in this direction myself
where if I'm like talking about the Hassan stuff I try not to
talk about the Destiny stuff because I'm just like people aren't
going to take me seriously and I I it sounds just a little goofy.
Okay.
But with Loader Box, he said some stuff today that I'm just like,
"Bro, I I really wish you wouldn't say this. I really wish you'd
just like not do it."
TLLD, no, you could say and watch. We don't I don't hate Loner
Box. I understand where I I can empathize with where the Lonerbox
stuff is coming from. I think Hassan has with Lonerbox and his
reputation a lot. I think I think Hassan took the totally wrong
approach with Lonerbox.
I think Hassan could have easily given an olive branch to litter
box and made this work. But instead, you know, he fights with
loner box a lot. He he maligns litter box a lot. He lets other
people on who malign litter box. I do think he could have easily
gone and made things work out with loner box in a way that helps
literally everybody. And I I just wish that I wish that hadn't
happened personally, but
with loner box, it was just the things he said. I was just like,
"Bro,
you make comments on me and Queenman that I was just like, I
really don't think you should be saying this. I really don't
think you should be saying this." Uh, but it's fine. >> People
love uh going on flotillas to
>> Yeah. What happened the last time that took place? Israel
slaughtered like 10 humanitarian activists.
He's such a >> Isn't Lonerbox a pretty big Israel apologist?
So I think Loaderbox was a pretty big like pro Palestine person
and then eventually he saw like basically some Hassan types that
he thought were exaggerating the pro Palestinian arguments making
them poorly and he also you know was collaborating with Destiny
and he ended up taking the side of Israel on some stuff and I
think he's still got a very strong command of all of the all
of the conflict. He knows a lot of the history in a way that
very few people do. So I don't actually disagree with lonerbox
probably a lot on the facts of the
of the I guess Israel Palestine conflict historically. I would
guess that I would agree with Lonerbox on a lot of it. I where
I disagree is in the more modern context. Okay. And I I
I'm going to say something crazy that a lot of people will get
very upset about. Okay. I think you have to go beyond what you
could prove and you do have to work off of vibes a little bit
to to truly have the correct opinion on Israel in the modern
day.
That's going to sound like I'm justifying some insane stuff,
but I I think you basically that's the conclusion I've come to
is like if you just look at what you can conclusively prove only,
you'll find that you can conclus conclusively prove very little.
But then you look into who's offiscating that information in
a lot of cases and it's like well
certain people who are obiscating that information. So I sound
just crazy when I say it. Okay, I sound crazy but I don't think
it's crazy.
All right, I do think it's crazy. Anyway, so that's that's my
opinion on like the modern what's going on in the at least since
October 7th with Israel.
So anyway,
uh let me see. I'm going to shoot Queen a message and just see
if he's going to hop on. He might want to cover this. So, he
might not hop on, but I'll just see. >> Israel dip rider.
It is crazy.
He's also still pining for Lawrence Southern. Unsure what he's
attempting to say because you're Turkish, huh? He's just like
he's just he knows how to needle you. Needle me? His
hatred for his derangement, his Hassan derangement syndrome is
so
maxed out that it has caused
literal people in his own orbit, people in his own sphere of
influence to go, "Yeah, you're out of your mind, man. You're
actually being a little weird about this shit." I I actually
I will say there's like levels to it. Like I already was on the
Hassan is bad stuff with Destiny where I thought they were like
misreading or misunderstanding or overstating the case against
Hassan.
I will say the techone more Pegasus
um like commentary sphere of people
that's like a step beyond again where they're not just saying
like well Hassan does bad political analysis so he's really bad.
They're like they're actually going beyond that. Okay. And they're
going like, "Actually,
you know, I understand. Don't look at Don't look at my case.
Don't look at my case in the in the courts, okay? Don't look
at my case.
Hassan [__] shocked his dog. Don't look at my case
suggesting that it's likely or sorry, it's reasonably likely
that I ored somebody." Hassan [__] shocked his dog.
That's I'm like, "Dude, that is a level beyond where like maybe
I'll say it's not totally outside. I understand how people believe
the um like some of the Hassan stuff, the the Marxist Leninist,
the communist stuff, how you know the Red Scare happened. I I
get how people end up in that position where they believe all
of that stuff and they're totally against Assan. I get it. With
the Techone stuff, I'm just like, "Dude, you guys are insane.
These people are [__] nuts, man. These people are
[__] nuts." Okay,
so it goes a level beyond. I still have criticisms, but I'm willing
to say I'm biased against like, you know, Destiny. I think he's
generally quite harmful, quite a bad person. So, I'm willing
to say that maybe my biases come into play there. But with the
Tetone stuff, I'm like, "Dude, this has gone beyond whatever
the Destiny stuff was. It's gone beyond to another level that
I'm just like, you guys are are you guys kidding me? We're going
to let we're going to let Nux
get out of like letting a 15-year-old rather turning 15 groomed.
We're going to let him get out of allowing that to happen in
his Discord. This 14-year-old was groomed into self harming and
dropping out of school, getting overly desensitized to gore,
all of this. We're going to let that slide cuz shocked his dog
cuz Hassan supported the Houthis.
We're really really We're going to let that defense work? We
can't let that defense work. I'm sorry. We can't do it. We can't
do it. We won't allow it. That's crazy. No shot. >> Identity
Europa or whatever in the little tugboat. Um >> yeah, comparing
uh comparing humanitarian aid flotillas
to what his uh what this girl, this white nationalist, he like
literally tried to
Why why did he bring that up? Wait, why did he bring up
Why did he bring up the identity Europa stuff?
Why would you bring that up? That's like the dumbest thing you
could possibly bring up.
which was to intercept refugees to them, refugees that were trying
to get to Europe to basically drop their boats, causing them
to die. Many of those ships had children in them for the record.
Comparing that to the exact opposite
is of course once again demonstrating that his politics are so
hollow
with the little flare things or whatever. That's basically it's
just like the grown-up version of that. like, "Oh, we're going
to get in a flotilla that doesn't have any real humanitarian
supplies in it." Knowing we're never going to reach this place
because >> also he's just making up the fact that there's
no humanitarian supplies in it.
>> We know that we're violating some naval blockade or
some naval thing. >> You have to be more specific with
him wanting to white supremacist. I mean, he has wanted to and
suck every Nazi for the record. Uh Nick Fuentes, Sam Hyde possibly
at some level because they did collaborate and definitely Lawrence
>> You despise him at a personal level. He lets it completely
warp his political ideology and taints all his you mean he despises
me as at a personal level, right? Cuz like I I dis I think his
world view is disgusting. I think his personal
uh I think the way he operates is disgusting in general. Like
I think he's a I I'm trying to think the world view Destiny espouses
before he got in all of this stuff I did not I do not find disgusting.
I do think he's sort of swapped up on some stuff. Like when he
calls Pixie like a an E or like a gold digging, I'm like, "Yeah,
you've totally flipped on all of the red pill stuff and you're
just totally on like Myron side now." I think that's pretty weird
to be honest with you. Um I think that's just very odd to me,
right? When he does that, I'm like, "Okay, that's that's totally
flipped and that's bizarre." But the world view he had before
that, the one he pretended to espouse, the one he pretended to
believe in, I I don't find that disgusting. So, >> freakish
little perve. But if he was like
a a normal liberal who didn't spend every waking moment trying
to like uhh talk about how I should be by his cult like cult
fans or whatever the like it would be I wouldn't give a [__]
Right. He also doesn't comprehend that like a big component of
this flotilla is not even just bringing in humanitarian aid which
of course exists in the flotillaa
but it's it's uh beyond that it's actually to bring awareness
of the blockade that is also taking place like the the activism
I don't know if there's a blockade taking place I mean there's
a there's like a trade embargo which is a little different I
don't think they embargo trade from other countries I don't think
they like block a trade from other countries. There is a trade
embargo from the US.
>> Yeah, but I don't think they
Sorry. They block they block trade from um there's an oil embargo
as well. Yeah, sure, sure, sure. They're blocking Well, is it
even an oil embargo? Cuz I thought I thought Russia and sorry,
Russia and China weren't going to send oil to Cuba cuz it's just
too far. And then I think like is the oil embargo not basically
that they were getting all of their oil from Venezuela, which
will no longer ship oil to them? They are starving them out.
They're causing a major They are intentionally causing a major
energy crisis in Cuba to try to overthrow that regime. That's
like the explicit tactics they're attempting to do. They're intentionally
causing an oil uh like an energy crisis in Cuba to topple that
regime for sure. Okay. Beyond that, >> it's twofold. Not
only are you bringing in much needed humanitarian supplies, but
you're also showcasing the everyday existence of Cubans. It's
like the PR and the visibility is a big component of
By the way, nobody would disagree with that. Nobody would disagree
that the US is manufacturing an energy crisis in Cuba to try
to topple that regime, to try to cause pressure on that regime
to cause them to get overthrown.
I don't think anybody would, no liberal commentator, no reasonable
commentator would disagree with that.
And then once we get intercepted, we can complain that it's a
human rights violation. You know, repeat admin. And then if you're
really, really lucky, someone on your boat will get shot by some
kind of Navy, US Coast Guard or something like that. >> Why
would that be lucky?
Yes. Yeah. To destabilize the regime in the country. Yes. That
and you have a huge media attention for you. Wait, what the [__]
There was a right-wing woman trying to actually kill refugees.
Yeah. This is back in the day. Identity Europa is a neo-Nazi
group.
Um and Lauren S. She's trying to kill refugees.
I think like I don't know what they would have done and maybe
you don't grant them any charity, but they were trying to send
boats back. Could those boats survive if they went back the other
way? I have no idea. I don't know if they cared. I think they
were mostly ineffective. So probably doesn't >> This white
nationalist YouTuber that Destiny has was was a part of that
and she was throwing up flares at like refugee boats. They were
shooting flares at a refugee boat. >> Also technically
incorrect. Okay. No shooting of flares at refugees.
>> Bro, when you say stuff like this,
when you say stuff like this, I I can't tell you what I think.
>> If you let D hit, you wouldn't have this
>> Hassan, why didn't you just let Destiny [__]
you? If you if you let Destiny you, he wouldn't even be a problem
anymore. He wouldn't even be going after you. Just let him just
let him [__] you.
[__] happened to you. But I'm thinking it. You know
what I mean?
Like when you say stuff like this, I I can't begin to explain
how disgusting of a repulsive freak you are for saying dumb like
that. Let him hit, bro. Let him hit. Like, I understand that
you're trying to make a joke about Destiny being a creepy little
Fallen H3 fans do this, too, and I hate them. Yeah, I I despise
that [__] I want nothing to do with this weird freak
who is literally a predator. His entire worldview is repulsive
to me. He's a bad person. He's a bad father.
I mean, objectively a bad father. his son is now a neo-Nazi
and it's directly a consequence of like him not paying him any
attention whatsoever. He's just a bad person in general.
He is an egoomaniacal loser. And the reality of the matter is
if his politics weren't dog [__] and if he wasn't
like like a weird sociopath
who constantly uses and abuses people
uh and and you know has engaged in a litany of of possible crimes
procured seam and I wouldn't have any issue with this person
at all if he was just like a regular ass lib. Why the would I
ever bring him up?
Yes, he has a child.
Uh that was shockingly like close to true. That was like he actually
went out of his way to not overexlain a bunch of the things.
I got the substance. We'll go over it. We'll just we'll do any
everything in chronological order here. So
we actually well maybe I can't actually cover this because I've
done the pisco thing already. But we um
Hassan was pretty accurate right there. Hassan didn't go out
of his way. Wasn't super hyperbolic as he is often with his who
he calls his ops. He wasn't super hyperbolic. just was calmly
like, "Yeah, this guy's like pretty gross and he's done like
crimes. He procures. He retains these." It's like, "Yeah, it's
all true.
It's all true."
He has no redeemable qualities. He's just a decent debater. And
for a lot of these like weird freaks on the internet, that's
all that matters for them cuz they see it as blood sports. It's
a holdover from uh the the neo-Nazi back and forth like blood
sports community back in the day which Destiny would debate all
the time. And he basically became their god because he defeated
all of these other dumb asses cuz they were all very stupid Nazis.
It wasn't like a like an impressive feat at all cuz they were
all incredibly stupid. And then he basically took on all of their
audience and became their champion.
And
um and in the process like the community's interest in in blood
sports never really went away. Uh and now every single day that
uh that goes by, he will every now and then debate another person.
Sometimes if he loses to a person that is more knowledgeable
than them uh more knowledgeable than him, he will sick his audience
on them uh forever.
Uh and they will just like engage in a cyberstalking operation
where they just like try to smear that person over and over again.
Myself included. Michael from Pennsylvania is another great example.
Um he's he's a skilled ortor exclusively because he is uh very
confident.
So I think part of my issue here is I I could keep going with
this, but I do think this comes up again in the Loner Box stuff.
I think Luner Box watches the same like stream segment. So I
don't know if I go any further here. I think I might be able
to move on to a couple of the clips and then we'll go to the
Lunarbox stuff after that. Lenin was awesome. What the >> What's
his problem?
>> Has admitted that he would ban opposing political parties
in the United States and would lock his enemies forever in reeducation
camps if they didn't agree with his political ideology.
>> All of these people, if you were to ask them like, "Wouldn't
you put some of the fascists in reeducation camps?" would say
yes at this point, by the way.
>> Oh, so all those dudes said, "Oh, he didn't actually
say reeducation camps. He just said re-education, not in a camp.
He's just going to be the He just completely changed the definition
of socialist re-education as we understand it for the last [__]
hundred years. Now it suddenly doesn't happen in a camp. It's
not like for the for the entire 20th century every time socialist
did re-education it was in a camp. I think I think Hassan just
wants to kill Nazis to be honest with you. No. Is not Hassan
just going like Nazis like literally just hang Nazis immediately.
I feel like that's all Hassan's saying here. But Hassan's the
first time where it's actually just uh >> like I I just
call me crazy. I feel like Hassan probably doesn't think that
people who believe in capitalism in some way and would advocate
for capitalism in a socialist world are just Nazis by default.
But maybe
you know [laughter] >> maybe maybe >> we'll just
we'll just run some ads.
>> Oh man, people are so stupid. >> What is this?
alleged
destiny says he's jealous of >> saying he's going to board
a flotilla to Cuba and a lot of you guys are saying there's no
shot that he does that he absolutely will do that flotillas are
like the best they're like the best um pointless PR [__]
that you can ever do that's probably the most Turkish I this
is rough it's rough that you basically have to like I don't know
how to I don't know how to fix this okay
it's so rough that
I I by the way My opinion is that Lurbox, if these two people
are on his screen ever, he just shouldn't comment. He should
just be like, "No, I don't want to comment on this."
Cuz what we're about to watch, I don't like. Okay. I just don't
like I don't like it.
And I get I get a little bit why it happens, but holy man's ever
done
love to go from Turkey to to Israel to stir some up. What you
do is you call yourself a humanitarian aid flotilla. Half your
ships or all of them are empty. You might have supplies in a
single boat. >> I will say it is such a
unbelievable grift that he's doing if he wants to do a flutella
to Cuba. Remember there >> I just
I listen I'm know that I'm I'm just holding back. I'm just holding
back. I'm just holding back. Okay. Sorry. We have to go back
to the time stamp which I just lost.
>> He said you're worse than your ships or all of a
>> Turkish thing he's ever done.
every time social did re-education.
Oh, here we go.
Right here
a flotilla to Cuba. And a lot of you guys are saying there's
no shot that he does that. He absolutely will do that. Flotillas
are like the best. They're like the best um pointless PR that
you can ever do. That's probably the most Turkish thing he's
ever done.
Love to go from Turkey to to Israel to stir some
>> Turkish thing he's ever done.
Fuckillas love to go from Turkey to to Israel to stir some [__]
up. What you do is you call yourself >> humanitarian aid
flotilla half your ships or all of them are empty. You might
have supplies in a single boat. >> I will say it is such
a
unbelievable grift that he's doing if he wants to do a flutilla
to Cuba. Remember there an armed an embargo is not a blockade.
Cuba is not blockaded. people from different countries are able
to send aid in ships to Cuba. Even >> I think this is true.
I will say it's obvious. Again, I'll just say it's obvious. I
said this before I watched Luna react, but it's like really obvious
that the US is attempting to cause an energy crisis to put pressure
on that regime, possibly topple it.
They've basically said this. It's not even remotely like it's
obvious that's what they're doing. They want to cause like mass
suffering to topple that regime. They're doing it intentionally.
They're they're like obviously doing it. Literally every single
geopolitical analyst believes they're doing that
>> in fact, that it could be even part of the rationale
for going to Venezuela the way they did. >> Organizations
are sending aid to Cuba. They're just sending it through churches,
not to uh the government. Uh not least of all, the American government
is sending aid to Cuba uh through the churches. This government
right now as they embargo the oil and trade. So if Assam wants
to give aid to Cuba, all he would have to do is well for just
send money to a different country that's sending like Mexico
sent ships to Cuba.
That's kind of I is anybody going to say that? I just have to
look at Lonox's chat.
I've seen like I've seen a bunch of different people say this.
Somebody in chat has to point this out, right? >> Pointless
PR. somebody in that chat who's willing to point out that it's
very obvious
that they're attempting to cause an energy crisis to topple that
>> you can ever do. That's probably the most Turkish thing
he's ever done.
Love to go from Turkey to to all of
>> Unbelievable. An armed an embargo is not a blockade.
Cuba is not blockade. People from different countries are able
to send aid in ships to Cuba. Even >> are they able to
send oil to Cuba to fix the energy crisis? >> Americans
organizations are sending aid >> like if Canada wanted
to send oil to Cuba right now, could they do that >> to
Cuba? They're just sending it through churches, not to uh the
government. Uh not least of all, the American government is sending
aid to Cuba uh through the churches. This government >> that's
that's like
I don't know. It just feels a little disingenuous, doesn't it?
It feels a little disingenuous to like explicitly look to [__]
this country's economy. I would imagine that the the consequences
of having no oil, of not being able to have any fuel to power
your country are cascading failure,
right? So, like you're going to send them food so they can get
through the cascading failure they're causing in the country.
I'm like, it feels pretty wrong, but maybe there's another side
of that. Maybe there's another side where it's like well
act I don't I actually don't know what the other side is to >> right
now as they embargo the oil and
>> No, but it's felp again it is that they are intentionally
creating an energy crisis in the country. They will not be able
to you won't be able to get gas. You won't be able to get anything
going on there, right? You won't be able to power anything in
an emergency situation. They'll eventually run out of ways to
power I think most of like a lot of their infrastructure,
right? Like they're they're causing an energy crisis intentionally.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Diesel. So you wouldn't be able
to get diesel either. Yeah. It's like
the their country is going to
like it's just guaranteeing like it's guaranteeing all kinds
of problems. >> So if Assam wants to give aid to Cuba,
all you would have to do is well for just send money to a different
country that's sending like Mexico sent ships to Cuba. So yeah,
the flotilla is actually it's a complete LAR. It is a
it's completely it's just it's just PR. It's just PR. >> And
then all of you are like media trained and press ready. You're
live streaming and broadcasting. You know that what you're doing
is probably illegal or is going to get intercept. It's basically
like the grown-up version of um of when Lauren Southern was with
>> yeah far superior is my method which is watching Hassan
[__] clips while playing Ark Raiders and Malding.
>> I mean they're they are in they're in practice the same
thing though, right?
You you are achieving the exact same amount apart from that one
is that a bunch of dribbling American college students will >> the
Lauren Southern mention like barely evaded me there again. God
damn it. Hold
>> Then all of you are like media trained and press ready.
You're live streaming and broadcasting. You know that what you're
doing is probably illegal or is going to get intercepted. It's
basically like the grown-up version of um of when Lauren Southern
was with um >> Yeah. far superior is my method which is
watching Hassan [__] clips while playing Arc Raiders
and Malding.
People are like, "Oh, I don't understand why Destiny would reference
Lawrence Southern there." He wants you to remember that he [__]
Lauren Southern. That's all. That's that's literally it. He's
like, "I hope you guys remember. I do you remember? Do you remember?
Can I get Can I get someone to react to this and point out that
I [__] Lauren Southern?" That's like actively what
he wants right now.
I mean they're they are in they're in practice the same thing
though, right?
>> you're achieving the exact same amount apart from that
one is that a bunch of dribbling American college students will
be very impressed by what you're doing because they'll associate
flotillaa with going to the Israeli blockade of Gaza and think
it's the same thing as going to Cuba with aid even though that
the the American government of all people is doing that. Not
to mention uh private citizens organizations. Somebody just pointed
something out which I do think is kind of interesting.
Are they going to include like oil to distribute this aid with
like fuel to distribute this aid with or are you just further
taxing their already taxed energy reserves?
Like are you actually are you actually do
cuz is it not
is it like I I wouldn't say it's morally bad. It's just like
are you helping the
If I gave you like a bunch of like freeze-dried stuff that you
could that was inedible without water and you didn't have water,
am I helping you a lot? It's like, dude, I'm giving you so much
food. It's like, yeah, well, unfortunately, take advantage of
that. I need this other thing.
Like, well, I can't I can't give you that other thing. Yeah,
I know. I know you can't give me that other thing. >> Uh,
other countries are sending aid to Cuba. They have done. The
Mexicans sent two full ships of it. Yeah. And it's going to it's
just going to have a lot more to say than whatever
little dingy boat with a pack of sandwiches that you guys are
going to bring. So
cringe. >> Did you guys notice he did a dog whistle at
the behest of Israel there when he was like Turkish people love
uh going on flotillas to Israel? >> Yeah. Why is that dog?
>> What happened the last time that took place? Israel
slaughtered like 10 humanitarian activists.
>> Sorry, the humanitarian activists. Am I confusing those
humanitarian activists with the uh the guys who were on the radio
saying go back to Avitz and when the ship got boarded they started
fighting the soldiers with like with homemade weapons.
Those humanitarian activists
>> I don't know what go back to Avitz has to do with humanitarianism.
I don't really know.
>> I mean
he he might not think it. I would say probably if you think these
people are like Nazis committing a genocide,
you might think the genocide done to them was like more justified
than before. You might make like a you might know that they get
upset at that and you might make reference to it probably.
Not saying that's good, man. I'm not saying it's good. It's probably
a pretty up thing to do to be honest.
It's probably a pretty [__] up thing to do,
but you might have, you know, you might find yourself overwhelmed
with emotion. It's really people tried to say that that clip
was like malicious or something. The malicious thing that they
did, the quote malicious thing that they did was that there were
numerous messages coming from the flotilla and they chopped up
the radio signals to get rid of the dead air. That was apparently
>> that was apparently the bad faith involved in that.
>> I don't know much about the mavar. >> He's such
a
>> Israel writer. It is crazy. >> Let's go. >> He's
also still pining for Lauren Southern. unsure what he's attempting
to say because you're Turkish, huh? He's just like he's just
he knows how to needle you. Needle me.
[laughter] His hatred for his deranged. We can all We can all
laugh when Hassan gets one guy by a random chatter. Okay, we
can all laugh.
Leftists liberals. Everybody can laugh when Hassan gets one guy
by He's totally beating you right now. He's beating me. >> Oh
god. He did not. >> He did not like [laughter] >> He
did not like being told that Destiny needles him.
>> No, he's got he's a he I needle him.
Oh, they're so funny. >> Oh, uh Nor McDonald has a great
bid on this that like essentially if you like truly hate somebody,
it's probably rough to do comedy on them because you actually
can't get the comedy right because of like your seething. He
says it differently. It's like your spite prevents you from like
getting the commentary like on on point. Like you I think he's
talking about impressions. Your impression will never be great
if you truly hate somebody. You cannot do a good impression of
them because you can't see them effectively. The impression will
never be like it'll never cut through like cultural noise because
he used to work on Saturday Night Live and he talked about how
people did fantastic impressions. I think the example he uses
is like the um the Alec Baldwin Trump versus the Trump that uh
the guy who used to do Madden on Saturday Night Live. That guy
used to do Trump as well. And apparently his Trump was really
good and Norm's hypothesis for this was basically like because
Alec Baldwin hates Trump so much. Yeah. Will Sasso or maybe Frank
Caliando. No, Frank Caliando. Frank Caliando. Not Will Sasso.
Frank Caliando. Um, yeah. And he basically says like the reason
for that is because Frank didn't hate Trump and you could get
you could get it like on point. I think some of that goes into
commentary a little bit as well. Um, is why yes, but
like this is a funny thing. I don't hate Hassan, so I could just
laugh at him like getting angry about that. He's needling me.
You chatter. I I think it's funny. I think it's hilarious. I
think we can all laugh at it. But then you see Loner Box and
like it's really just like he doesn't like the guy.
He just really doesn't like the guy.
I'll be honest. This is why I cover Destiny less cuz while I
don't think my coverage was ever bad, I just think it's like
I actually don't like the person. And so probably the commentary
and jokes, it's just like not going to land the same.
And it's just more fun to cover other people cuz I just don't
have the same like dislike for them, disdain for them.
Literal people in his own orbit, people in his own sphere of
influence to go, "Yeah, you're out of your mind, man. You're
actually being >> pretty sure the pair of these guys just
talk about each other every single stream. It's just like it's
been the routine for like years now. What? Okay. I know it's
not had a phase where he >> on the ground >> wouldn't
even
lug. I'm pretty sure Luner Box, if I remember correctly, is not
going to let that comment go. >> People in his sphere of
influence. Who are who are those people? >> Name Destiny.
But
>> oh, that was also funny because I didn't hate Hassan
Kleinhila. That was also funny because I didn't hate Hassan.
That I truly believe that coverage was still funny because I
didn't have like a burning hatred for the guy. I genuinely thought
he was funny a lot of the time. Like I thought it was funny to
cover him. I still find him funny in like the exact same ways.
By the way, I still find the old bits funny as if I ever have
a reason to pull up the clips of him kicking that uh with the
coach doing the kicks or his like kick in that gym, I still bring
that stuff up. It's all still funny in the same way. Ah, the
great outdoors >> being a little weird about this.
>> I don't even know why. Like
what needle? Yeah. Would I really? I don't know why there's any
shame in saying that. Like if I say, "Yeah, Hassan does kind
of needle me sometimes." Yes, I get triggered when people are
stupid. Yes, confident stupidity is really annoying to me. Yeah,
it needles me. So, it's also kind of funny, but it's also sometimes
very
Like, what's wrong with saying that? Oh, you're just a man having
derangement syndrome. Okay.
>> Identity Europa or whatever in the little tugboat. Um
>> yeah. Comparing
uh comparing humanitarian aid flotillas
>> to what his uh what this girl this white nationalist
he like literally tried to Whoa. Which was to intercept refugees
to kill them.
>> Is it lore though? >> Refugees that were trying
to get to Europe to basically drop their boat. >> Whoa.
Never heard of that before. The thing everybody knows happened.
boats causing them to die. Many of those ships had children in
them for the record. Comparing that to the exact opposite, >> what
Lauren did with the boats was like pretty horrible. No one no
one actually remembers what happened in that video. It's so funny
how that situation just
cuz I covered that when um when she came back cuz she was basically
lying about the story. Um what she did was there was a boat that
was on its way out to go and rescue people who were drowning,
>> Or not drowning, sorry. It was like what happens was
that people would go out in these um either fishing boats or
dinghy boats into the Mediterranean. And these boats are they're
not built to be in the open sea. So what people do is they would
leave usually Libya in this situation. They would leave Libya
in these boats and then once they had left the uh maritime area
and gotten past the coast guards, they would send out a distress
call to Italy and then Italy would pick up their distress call
and say, "Oh, there's some people on a little fishing boat. Let's
go get them and take them onto the ship." and Lauren and her
little gang of hoodlams went to this boat that was empty. I don't
know why I'm signed saying there were children on the ship by
the way. We just made that up for comical fact I guess. Uh there
was no like there was only uh rescue workers who were on the
ship because they were flee they were sailing out to the Mediterranean
to go and pick people up >> because probably doesn't know
the Hassan is very imprecise when he describes these things.
Hassan probably doesn't know the difference between her, you
know, like trying to flag down one of these ships, trying to
go after one of the ships directly. Uh, everybody told this story
for a long time. By the way, the narrative about this story is
literally, yeah, he's defending Lauren Southern, but the narrative
about this story is just not what the reality was at all. Like,
the narrative is Hassan's saying what every single DJ has said
about that event forever, always, right? That she shot flares
at immigrant workers. Even Destiny gets this wrong still. Even
Destiny will still make jokes about this or say it happened,
right? Cuz that's like what every that's what somehow that became
what happened. And Lord Box is trying to correct to what it actually
was to go and ostensibly respond to a distress call. And then
they went in front of the boat and they were like, "No, no illegal
immigration. No, no." And they waved those like little hand flares
and then they quickly realized that the ship wasn't stopping
for them [laughter] and then they got out of the way. That's
what she did. So what she basically did was
she tried to block this boat from going out the Mediterranean.
Uh even though there is a
nonzero chance that the people who that boat was going to get
were might have capsized in that time cuz you know like let's
say she succeeds in stopping the boat for 5 minutes and then
just by sheer chance one of these ding I think it was like 120
at that time. There was no 150
votes. Um this should have ties and maybe people went around.
Uh no one really tells us that's already
arrested for that. She was for that. Um but yeah, >> yeah.
Well, I I know Desi repeated it years ago. I want to say he did
it just recently. Like he made a reference to it just recently
and I laughed about it cuz I'm like, dude, I remember where Lauren
came on and corrected you on this that this didn't happen. It's
funny that he was he was probably signaling against a right-winger
at that point in time or something. I'm guessing maybe Asmin
Gold or something. So, he just gets in his emotions and he just
he's like, "Rightwinger's bad." And he probably said this. I
I trust me, I don't remember the situation, but I'm willing to
bet it was something like that. Okay. Where he just like not
care about what the truth was, he'd just say it again. >> One
of the worst things I've ever seen YouTuber do
>> maybe it's different. Hold on. >> [__]
hollow.
I mean
>> sorry
I I left it >> of course once again demonstrating that
his politics are so hollow.
>> Why is Loner so fixated on that though? Um I don't mind
being precise. I don't mind if you want to point out that other
people are imprecise cuz I do it basically. I like being precise.
I like saying things correctly. So,
uh, I I don't mind Loader Box pausing to just be like, "Actually,
what what really happened here is this >> with the little
flare things or whatever." That's basically it's just like the
grown-up version of that. Like, oh, we're going to get a flotilla
that doesn't have any real humanitarian supplies in it knowing
we're never going to reach this place. >> Also, he's just
making up the fact that there's no humanitarian supplies in it.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I guess there's a few boxes
of of crackers in your little pogbo. Do you know the the difference
in size between like an aid vessel uh like Mexico is literally
sending hundreds of tons of aid to uh
How many are you even going to get one ton into this flotilla
or it's just it just this happened with the Greta Thunderberg
flotilla as well. It wasn't even enough aid for like half a truck.
But okay, that's why then why why did was there any press on
Greta Thunberg's thing? Why did Israel like do anything to track
that or do anything about it? Why didn't they just let that [__]
go?
It's like totally performative. Why did you why did they do anything
about it? Didn't she get arrested?
Why' they even
There's like nothing there. Why did they even care? >> A
lot of these aid organizations when people talk about bringing
supplies down or whatever to Ukraine or usually these organizations
will just say, "No, just give us money." Like you're you're actually
more trouble than you're worth if you try to bring >> They
made her kiss the flag.
There's no way they literally made her kiss an Israeli flag.
That has to be a metaphor, not a That has to be a joke.
She got beat up. Okay. I
didn't She claim to be captured and by Israel. I hope not. Oh,
like cavity searches. Gross.
Gross. Gross. Gross. >> Stuff over. The flotillaa is just
a PR stunt. It's pointless. Especially in Cuba where there's
not even a blockade. It's an embargo. It's not the same as a
blockade. People can bring stuff to Cuba if they want to.
>> We know that we're violating some naval blockade or
some naval thing. >> You have to be more specific with
him wanting to premises. I mean, he has wanted to and suck every
Nazi for the record. single >> Nick Quentes, Sam Hyde possibly
at some level because they did collaborate and >> Britney
from Politically Provoked. In fact, [laughter] >> that's
another Nazi. I guess maybe they they're losing track of the
Nazis or whatever. There is another one actually. >> Definitely
Lauren Southern. You despise him at a personal level. He lets
it completely warp his political ideology and taints all his
You mean he despises me as at a personal level, right? Cuz like
I I dis I think his worldview is disgusting. I think his personal
uh I think the way he operates is disgusting in general. Like
I think he's a a freakish little perve. But if he was like a
a normal liberal who didn't spend every waking moment trying
to like uh uh talk about how I should be by his cult like cult
fans or whatever the like it would be I wouldn't give a >> I
thought we were doing the live and learn react. What is this?
It's become a destiny tangent. >> He also doesn't comprehend
that like a big component of this flotilla.
>> This is a different clip, isn't it? Or maybe he did
these clips back to back. >> Is not even just bringing
in humanitarian aid, which of course exists in the flotilla.
>> Uh, of course it exists in the flotilla. Yes, that yes,
there's some food on the Well done, buddy. Well done.
>> It's It's uh beyond that. It's actually to bring a >> To
be fair, I think this was categorically proven before Andrew
Wilson like put it out there. Simpo,
this is if you care to actually go look at the evidence, which
unfortunately, you know, for better or worse, was in Kiwi Farms
was on in his Kiwi Farms thread. The guy who like made the Kiwi
Farms post, it's like the it's exactly like the um the Amir skitsos
or the the OTV skitsos, it's the exact thing. It's like, yeah,
like categorical proof was laid out. And if you didn't want to
look at it, that's fine. But for people who are like, "Oh, that
was just a rumor." No, it wasn't. No, it wasn't. It was not just
a rumor,
but it's fine. It is what it is. >> Awareness of the blockade
is also taking >> It's not a blockade. It's not a
>> The unfortunately the same person did the same thing
to Lunar Box and uh Pixie to like say that they were dating,
right? Is that not Or maybe it wasn't the same person, but it
was the same thread that like they apparently both took they
both streamed or took pictures from like the same bed frame or
something. Listen,
we don't we don't know about that kind of thing, but it's like
when it happens, you know, we we report on it possibly. >> That's
why Oh, but >> probably he he actually really really really
needs it to be a blockade because blockade is the only time when
a fleet would make any sense. It's not a blockade. It's an embargo,
which means that there's not going to if you tried to go there
with some aid, it's not going to there's not going to be a big
American Navy vessel with guns trying to stop you.
[screaming and groaning] >> Does he think that's
Can someone just ask like really?
So I I guess they're going to say flotillaa in these people's
minds means automatically like aid vessels. Flotillaa I think
just means like collection of v vessels, right? It doesn't mean
like literally when they talked about what was floating off the
coast of Venezuela, I believe they called that a flotillaa multiple
times,
No, no, no, no, no, no. It's not I don't believe it's a raft.
A fleet of ships or boats is a flotilla.
Yeah, it's not a raft. No, a a raft is not a flotilla.
That's not what it means. Like when you talk about what's sitting
off the the coast of Venezuela, what was sitting there around
Puerto Rico, that's a flotilla. It's just it literally just means
the same thing. A fleet of ships or boats, an indefinite or large
number
Especially a navy organizational unit consisting of two or more
squadrons of small warships.
Like I guess I I understand the argument they're making is like
it evokes something in the mind of people who know about the
Mavi Mabara, but a flotilla is not a raft.
It's not a floating thing. It sounds like it's a floating thing,
but a flotilla is just a group of boats.
>> Really? Is that what's going to happen? You think that
you're going to get boarded by American soldiers stopping you
from bringing stuff blockade me?
>> The activism
uh the activism there is twofold. Not only are you bringing in
much needed humanitarian supplies, but you're also showcasing
the everyday existence of Cubans. It's like the PR and the visibility
is a big component of this. >> Oh, I know it's a big component
of that. >> And then once we get intercepted, we can complain
that it's a human rights violation, you know, repeated. And then
if you're really really lucky, someone on your boat will get
shot by some kind of Navy. >> I I just
I don't think
I don't feel like is is Han Maybe he is.
Do people believe it? If Assan says like, "I'm changing the world
by doing this." If he were to say that, maybe he does believe
it. I don't even want to speculate at his at his mental state.
Does anybody take that seriously? Or he just feel like he's doing
that to basically say, "Look, this is happening in Cuba. I'm
going to go to Cuba. I'm going to catch some sun. I'm going to
wear some Hawaiian shirts. I'm going to get a cool hat." Han's
going to get a very cool hat. Okay? Kind of like this hat. Actually,
Hassan may wear this exact outfit that my penguin's wearing.
Okay? And he's going to make at some point he's going to go,
"Look, look, I'm in the CIA. I I promise if that joke doesn't
happen, I will donate $50 to some charity. Okay? Write it down
right now. If he doesn't make that joke at some point, wearing
a Hawaiian outfit and a little hat, if he doesn't go and say,
"Oh, look, I'm in the CIA." I
$50.
>> US Coast Guard. Like, >> why would that be lucky?
>> You're lucky. >> So, just anybody who's sitting
here like, "Hosan's pretending he's saving the world." I I haven't
seen that. But even if he was, aren't you just like, "No, you're
not. You just want to go. You just want to go. You just want
to go to Cuba, man. >> And you have a huge media. >> Wait,
what the [__] There was a right-wing woman trying
to actually kill refugees. Yeah, this is back in the day. Identity
Europa is a neo-Nazi group. Um, and Lauren Southern, this white
nationalist YouTuber that Destiny has
uh was was a part of that and she was throwing up flares at like
>> I keep forgetting about this Destiny Lauren Southern
lore. [laughter] I
think the first time I found out about it was through a stream.
But now I've just been reminded of it again. Okay,
>> I I sort of personally actually I'll go ahead and say
Litterbox is just lying. Why is Litterbox pretending he didn't
follow that Chud stream? The Chud Mr. Girl report thing. Why
is he pretending he wouldn't have been involved or or paid attention
to that at all? Come on, man.
That's just an outright lie. Come
>> Refugee boats. They were shooting flares at a refugee
boat. Bro, when you say stuff like this, >> when you say
stuff like this, >> pretty sure it's the next possible.
>> I can't tell you what I think should happen to you,
but I'm thinking it. You know what I mean? >> Pretty sure
what they say. >> When you say stuff like this, I I >> Are
we going to go back to live and learn or is this literally just
a He spoke about Live and Learn for like 5 seconds and then went
on to a Destiny tangent and now we're talking about
Steven's Lawrence Southern like, "Okay, thank you."
Paul H3 fans do this to and I hate them. Yeah, I I despise that.
I want nothing to do with this weird freak who is literally a
predator.
>> His entire worldview is repulsive to me. A bad >> I
do I do find it a little funny as well. Hassan's so obsessed
with Destiny. I can't believe Hassan's talking about Destiny.
It's like Wait, what is this? What What is this supposed to be?
I actually don't What is this?
Who is that? Who Who is that? Who is that? Who is that right
there? I can't I can't tell. >> Person. He's a bad father.
I mean, objectively a bad father. His [laughter] son is now a
neo-Nazi
and it's directly a consequence of like him not paying him any
attention whatsoever. He's just a bad person in general. >> He
is an egoomaniacal loser.
>> I just I've noticed the parts where Loner Box does I'll
just I'll point out to you guys, okay? Every time even when Loader
Box has like a tiny shred of place he can push back here when
Hassan's speaking, he does so immediately. So when he doesn't
say anything, I'll just point out that that that probably speaks
volumes. Okay. He probably goes, "Yeah, I'm cooked on that >> Bad
person. He's a bad father. I mean, objectively a bad father.
His son is now a neo-Nazi.
And it's directly a consequence of like him not paying him any
attention whatsoever. He's just a bad person in general. >> He
is an egoomaniacal loser.
>> We went on like a 10-minute rant about how Lauren Southern
didn't actually shoot a flare, but right here we're like, actually,
you know what? Um,
okay.
And the reality of the matter is if his politics weren't dog
[__] and if he wasn't like like a weird sociopath
who constantly uses and abuses people uh and and you know has
engaged in a litany of of possible crimes procured seam. I wouldn't
have any issue with this person at all if he was just like a
regular ass lib. Why the would I ever bring him up? >> Yeah
because uh >> oh uh oh he made a face >> would I
ever bring him up? I wouldn't have any issue with this person
at all if he was just like a regular ass lib. Why the would I
ever bring >> procured sea salmon [__]
>> He he made a face. >> Yeah, because you treat
the regular libs uh so very very well. Didn't Has I had a spur
out over contra points? Okay,
>> Why is contra points a lib? >> Are we watching
this? Well, this started as a discussion about him reacting to
the lib and learn debate with the Epstein
uh hyperangle, [screaming] but now I'm just learning about how
much Han wants to talk about.
I'm just being reminded that Destiny may or may not have Lauren
Southern. Okay, thank you. >> May or may or may not have
May or may not have
May or may not have Oh, that is actually a great great question
or great point. Who are the people here? Who are the people here
who are like, why are we even watching this? Why are we even
watching this?
>> Did he call Contra a genocide? A genocide noir? I don't
know though. Maybe maybe Contra Points has committed some crimes
maybe that I don't know
Yes, he has a child.
>> Feel like I feel like you can criticize people for things
you disagree with. Yeah, he disagreed on Contra Point's like
stance on Israel Palestine. The the whole post she made that
can you only do that if you like think they're a
>> He has no redeemable qualities. He's just a decent debater.
And for a lot of these like weird freaks on the internet, that's
all that matters for them because they see it as blood sports.
It's a holdover from uh the the neo-Nazi back and forth like
blood sports community back in the day which Destiny would debate
all the time. And he basically became their god because he defeated
all of these other dumb asses cuz they're all very stupid Nazis.
It wasn't like a >> that's why I I didn't want to go through
this whole clip cuz we're going to come back to it with loner
box anyway. >> An impressive feed at all cuz they were
all incredibly stupid. And then he basically took on all of their
audience and became their champion.
>> And um and in the process like the community's interest
in in blood sports never really went away. >> Uh and now
every single day that that goes by, he will every now and then
debate another person. Sometimes if he loses to a person that
is more knowledgeable than them, uh more knowledgeable than him,
he will sick his audience on them uh forever
uh and they will just like engage in a cyberstalking
>> How often does he how often does he talk about this?
I feel like I've heard I feel like over the years I've heard
this exact same saliloquy. Is that what you call it? >> I
I I
just feel like I have so many like mixed feelings on this.
I just personally feel like he hadn't paused at like the cyberstalking
harassment thing to make this point if he was going to make it
because
well while I do think that like Hassan probably personally is
not necessarily like the biggest victim at this point in time.
That's actually probably Pixie.
I just I feel like Loaderbox shouldn't cast doubt on this. I
just wish he wouldn't be, but maybe he doesn't feel like he's
casting doubt on this, but like is Destiny not basically saying
that Pixie was like a total who would anybody she could to get
any amount of clout she could? I just I feel like the amount
of times he says this this kind of about Pixie, I understand
why Lunox wanted to opt out of it, but now he's like now he's
here like making reference to it in a way that is like sort of
going around the edge and I'm like, "Oh, I don't I don't really
like your
I I really don't like the opinion to be honest with you. >> Just
like slightly edited each time. You know how a lot of uh uh piano
sonatas especially people like Beethovven, you know, a lot of
the sonatas were actually improvised like you wouldn't always
play them the same way every time. Just the written down version
is the one that stuck for a few of them. Uh, and actually back
in the day, composers would often encourage people to improvise
with like their motifs like
is that what Hassan does? But with his chronicling of
of Destiny's [laughter]
I mean right here, he's just basically saying that Hassan's like
Mozart to him right now. I can't really [laughter]
destro
time stamp. I know about it. I personally I'm just going through
like this thing cuz I'm about to be referenced in like 2 seconds.
So
that's honestly the reason I'm going through this. I usually
would just leave it alone. But >> anyway,
where they just like try to smear that person over and over.
>> Kind of interested now. I'm just kind of curious to
see how Hassan does this, how he uh how he does his like how
he does his world building, how he deals with his detractors.
Swans do that in their live shows. Swans like the animals. What?
>> So an hour of starking for I guess so. I guess so. >> Included.
Michael from Pennsylvania is another great example. >> I
thought this was going to be like two and a half hours to start
stream. We're stretched out to 4 and 1/2 hours now. >> Um
he's a skilled order exclusively because he is uh very confident.
>> Very very confident. But obviously when he met his match,
someone who is far superior in intellect and far more knowledgeable
than him like Norm Finkelestein, he got ritualistically humiliated
on the timeline. uh you know flew too close to the sun and he
hasn't really recovered since then and he is still very much
pro- Israel. He just takes the the worst positions possible.
He's basically like the also the loyalists like the the unionists
in the north of Ireland. uh practically
>> I'm I'm seeing the glorious the glorious bastards meme
with [laughter] the uh
>> um I do believe Gupto I do believe this is primarily
I have to believe this is mostly or largely motivated by Hassan
going after lonerbox and being pretty disingenuous with lonerbox
which I which has happened absolutely I have to believe that
it's mostly motivated by that because I just I don't I truly
don't believe that it's motivated out of a want to like defend
Destiny in some way I think he's just mostly like shocking Assad.
I I think
Anyway, back to >> as the the unionists who fought against
the uh army of Republicans in the northern hemisphere of uh the
nation of Ireland. [laughter] Oh god, it sounds like Wait, where
is it? Is there a clip for this? Is there a reference? I think
there is. The north >> and Destiny never did that, right?
Uh Destiny did do that, but Lerbox when Destiny did that when
Destiny called like Lerbox a and stuff. I think Lunarbox went
through and like actually explained how Destiny was lying
and then basically said he didn't want to talk about it anymore.
So, it's not like he didn't respond when Destiny did that to
him. >> Worth of Ireland. Oh god. Yeah. Destiny in a rangers
kit. [laughter] Destiny going to be a hun.
That's what you call them, right? The unionists, the Huns. >> I
don't know what this is. >> Out of disadvantage, >> bro.
I feel bad. Did I fall asleep? I I like I literally woke up and
I I think I hadn't gotten enough sleep yet and somebody had sent
me the time stamp for this. I like started listening and somehow
I remember all of this way closer together and I'm like was I
just like cuz I was falling in and out of sleep. I was hitting
snooze on my alarm. I just wonder like how long was I in bed
for like listening to this and falling back asleep cuz I swear
all of the things I remember happened all in a row and now I'm
finding out that maybe somebody clipped it or something. No,
it I just I I'm not saying it was boring. I literally was like
not I hadn't gotten enough sleep when I started it. So, I started
on my YouTube app and then I went to sleep. Like I just basically
was listening to it, fell back asleep. Um cuz I like listening
to stuff when I'm going to sleep. But um it's funny. I I swear
all this stuff is closer together.
>> Reliable network of of cyber stalkers. Okay, hold on.
>> She's kind of like lost in what she's saying and she
just kind of goes like especially if you're um fasting during
uh during Eid.
the north of Ireland, >> the wrong side of every political
equation. Why do you still cover this guy? He's more relevant
than ever. I don't get the point of highlighting him as some
important all controlling figure. Um, he still has a pretty reliable
uh network of of cyberstalkers
and the only reason why his influence is actually falling apart
is due to his own actions like harming his own community members
and harming his own like uh content creators that have come out
of his own community >> and now they're all eating his
ass alive. So, every now and then I want to prop up the people
who are doing that, you know. >> Wait, hold on. Okay, first
of all, that's funny, but but also hold on. It sounded like Litterbox
agreed that it's mostly due to Destiny's own actions. Hold on.
It sounded like he agreed. I have to give him that >> for
this guy. He's more relevant than ever. I don't get the point
of highlighting him as some important alling fig. >> I
thought I heard him I thought I heard him basically say go like
Mhm. Mhm. like agreeing there. Um he still has a pretty reliable
uh network of of cyberstalkers
and the only reason why his influence has actually fallen apart
is due to his own actions like harming his own community members
and harming his own like uh content creators that have come out
of his >> Oh yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. Let's go loner box. Oh
yeah. That's Listen, I'm counting that one. I'm counting that
one. I'm counting that one. Community and now they're all eating
his ass alive. So every now and then I want to prop up the people
who are doing that, you know. But a lot of the uh anti-hassan
like >> it is kind of funny that um because I don't like
this next >> I have a memory right I remember how the likes
of Jay talk and Queman used to talk about Hassan before the event
and I never really understood that I never because they shifted
so hard in the way that they talk about I I never really understood
how that was supposed to work though like
magic magic just like me waking up when I heard this part of
my stream. It's crazy stuff how that works every time.
Okay. All right. Hold on. I'll pull it back here. Give me a >> I
have a memory, right? I remember how the likes of Jay Talk and
Quean used to talk about Assan before the event and I never really
understood that. I never because they shifted so hard in the
way that they talk about. I I never really went back >> how
that was on my channel. I searched a song on my channel. I never
did like some bad content. I've literally never done bad content.
There's like two or three videos that could be construed that
way and they're about Froggen. Uh, and then one of them is actually
me chit talking Stardust video on Froggen. Uh, so that I don't
even think I was really going after Froggen in that one. So,
I've literally I've never done this content. I've never been
that guy. I don't know what he's even referring to here. Uh,
the only thing I flipped on is is Israel. And my position on
Israel in the first place was basically just >> where it
seems like it's inevitable that they're going to do what they
do. So it but I mean tides have changed and the US is you know
kind of like a pariah state right now. So
on the Israel front yeah I think Israel is what changed a lot
for me was I basically thought Hassan was an extremist on Israel.
I thought he was like supported terrorist and extremist on Israel.
And as Israel got more extreme in their action I learned more
about like what's happening the modern day in the conflict. I've
seen the influence they have in the US and and how they wield
it. I'm like, "Oh, actually, I I don't think Assan's totally
insane for those opinions." I might still disagree with a lot
of them, but I don't think it's like totally out of this world
insane extremist opinion. I just I'm like, "Okay, I understand.
I don't know." The other stuff was just like snarking. It was
just like making fun of, you know, Hassan. And I do the same
thing. I still laugh at all the same eccentricities from Hassan.
>> Like when he gets one guy by somebody, I laugh in the
same way. I was looking back and l I was going through my content
seeing like what song content did I do before I started being
more critical of the ETH and stuff. It's like I I spoke briefly
I think about the the tier list stuff and I said yeah I mean
it's definitely a racial tier list
but I mean that's as far as I went with it. I was never going
crazy over it. Do you know what I mean?
>> well, and I feel like we had a whole arc where like
this stream's content was like me, you and Dan hanging out and
just like us making fun of how histrionic Dan was being >> push
pushing back and Yeah. and like telling him he's crashing out
and Yeah. Exactly. And um yeah, I went back and it's stuff like
yo, I covered like the Alysa Mckanti TwitchCon thing. So, I'm
not I'm not like talking about how much I hate Hassan there.
I'm just laughing about how awkward and the West McCy is and
how he handles it. >> It's like there's no point where
in my career and my online presence where I was like super super
anti-Han. There's like some tweets where I'm making fun of his
fashion sense or calling him a grifter. But like other than that
it's it's like pretty tepid stuff to be honest. Yeah, I was super
anti-Hassan in a way that like my whole friend group was like
I was I was leaning into stuff that I was like um yeah, I was
just leaning in and also I'd get like fed a ton of like clips
and from him like I could see you know how when somebody doesn't
like Nicholas Dioro and they find like a private moment in his
Discord and they link you that and you end up doing like more
like you it is funny. I feel like that's the same thing is like
I knew all the people who hated Hassan so they'd send me stuff
to like cover on Hassan. I'm like yeah you know it is what it
is. It's funny.
I don't know. I I was like you were
>> like uh probably stuff related to like Lwig as well
like the >> like her son asking him to take videos down
and stuff. That's gay. I'd say that's gay now. Yeah, that is
gay to ask me to take drama videos down. That is
>> But like that's not >> that's not like earthshattering
criticism. It's not like well you're the worst person ever. I
hate you. Then like >> my core I'm I'm going to literally
make a million videos about you. Every single day of my life
is going to be about how you were an extremist and you're terrible
and you're tearing the world apart. So it's not that level. >> Yeah.
And I >> I like disagree with politics. I just have far
less disagreement now. And I think there's like a couple things
going on there. Your mic's also going in and out by the way.
But um >> there's probably nothing I can do about that.
Well, there is. But >> yeah. Okay. [laughter] there with
regards to Hassan. It's like I still think like I don't agree
with the politics. I would say probably the the only thing that
changed in terms of like you it's hard to explain this change
to people is I sort of started to see how a lot of the tilts
I had against people like my my personal biases against them
I just tried to reset all of them after the whole thing happened
with Destiny. I just like trying to reset them and try to reevaluate
who I thought these people were, right?
And I think I came to a more neutral position on Hassan.
Um, some of the people around him I still thought were pretty
cringe, but on him I was like, eh, like fairly neutral. I don't
know.
And I I I'd say probably the unfortunate thing is you don't even
get that in my content. You don't even get that I like feel more
neutral on Hassan. What you get in my content is basically like,
oh, between Hassan and Yeah, Hassan probably. Like that's literally
the content I do is like when you are trying to excuse you by
invoking Hassan shocking his dog or when you're trying to say
you would vote for Adolf Hit over Hassan. I'm like yeah you cringe
bro. That's like the content that's like the only content the
only change you perceive in my content. You don't even change
like my actual opinion on the guy changing. Sorry. You don't
even perceive that. Like in the content it's like I'm like yeah
Hassan's probably not one of the bottom five human beings in
existence like of all time. And that's what they crash out about
is oh you you won't admit that Hassan is like one of the worst
people on earth. Excuse me. Excuse me. >> No, he's actually
not even about that at this point. Well, Hassan's just like
preferable to a lot of people and going after the right people
now. So, you
>> I didn't have a big this massive problem with them in
the first place. The other thing that got very frustrating uh
right off the bat as well was that Asmin Gold and Nikki Nicholas
uh Fuentes, Nick Fuentes were like ast they were just rising
astronomically.
Yeah, I mean still still kind of are still kind of on on top
and you know there's like this whole pocket of there's a whole
access of Chibi Knox Techone tried to recruit Destiny you know
it just literally everyone it is just all my enemies in one place
and you know like I say I I was never that much against Hassan
in the first place. So, I've got no issue with being like, "Yeah,
you know what? I'll cover Hassan winning. I'll cover when Hassan's
these people cuz
>> that I'm on board with that.
>> I agree with Hassan. I agree with on this. I agree with
Asan. You know, it's ultimately and it is like narcissism of
small differences ultimately with Hassan and Labs and Destiny
and all this because really they are closer than they want to
pretend and that's for both sides. you know, Han will pretend
he's further from from Destiny and lo Box than he is when really
it's about Israel. That's like the main >> the main diverging
point. And then like quite how far they want to go with left-leaning
policy, you know? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Quite how far they want to go with leftwing policy was how he
finished that off for you guys. >> I don't know how you
would hear that hear the rest of that and not the ending. I literally
don't know why a noise gate would make it so when I spoke volume
the whole time and didn't move. I truly don't I actually don't
know why it goes down so hard like that.
Yeah. Anyway, yeah, I don't get it. I actually it makes no sense.
I do think Yeah, it's I the hypothetical stuff has driven that
home, right? That like it's driven home the idea that they don't
see it that way. Like they're trying to make it not that. And
it clearly is that like yeah, you're all pulling the same direction
broadly, but like you have some minor disagreements and they're
trying to make it into something bigger. It's like trying to
manufacture that that extra thing.
That's why they have to do the Well, Hassan actually on the hunt
the what is the podcast called? Whatever that podcast is with
the leftists on that one podcast at one time he said he hides
he hides his uh power level. So we have to assume he's lying
always. Now it's just like, okay, I know. Whatever, man. Whatever,
man.
All right. I don't even know. Lot is going to go to into further
detail explaining how we uh how we turned our backs on all things
liberal. Okay. >> Because they shifted so hard in the way
that they talk about. I I never really understood how that was
supposed to work though. Like like I'm probably still I don't
have any plans to talk to Destiny or to even try to or to try
and make amends or whatever. I'm not really looking for that.
Um but I I I didn't realize that. >> Oh yeah. So lob he
didn't um abuse my >> Yeah. Damn. >> Yeah. I just
I'd probably have a different opinion if that was the case. It's
like yeah no you don't want to make amends with Destiny. >> I
would I would hope just anyone who was friends with her or any
of the other people like if you were just friends with them you'd
be like yeah I actually you you suck.
seems pretty simple, but >> being pretty mad at him meant
that I had to kind of change all the opinions that I agreed with
him on as well, which is Yeah, I never got >> Oh, here's
another great point. I think Lonerox was lucky in that he had
way more knowledge on Israel Palestine than I did. And so, he
didn't have to shift his worldview as new information came about
because he wasn't being made aware of like new things. So, I'll
I'll just give him that. He knew way more about Israel Palestine
than me. So he didn't have to shift his worldview a whole bunch.
My worldview shifted pretty significantly when I learned more
about Israel Palestine.
Yeah, that's fully on the table. When I learned more that that
got super concerning to me. So yeah,
that's it. >> I never understood how that happens. Hi Kiwi
Farms. Might as well give them a low that I just said that.
>> Does that Do people even care? Do people even clip Destiny
stuff to there anymore? I'm not I'm not sure. That's like the
most dead threat on that entire site at this point. People literally
don't care. >> Free association. All right. >> A
lot of the Hassan derangement syndrome. He is at the >> He
it might get clipped now cuz he did the reference though, unfortunately.
>> At the heart of he has no morals, no principles, no
values. He supports the opposite of whatever he thinks you support.
Pure spite based values. Yeah, >> Okay, I just paused.
Whoops. Um, and while he is uh while he is utterly irrelevant
in the grand scheme of things, uh, the reality of the matter
is he still very much has a bunch of like these edgelord centrist
content creators who do like a steady flow of focus on content
because they basically use all the talking points that they create
in his subreddit.
So he has a he has a a fairly sophisticated smearing and outrage
manufacturing operation. >> Like like I thought you people
like like that would [__] on Assan because they thought
Asan was cringe. I didn't know it was part of like
I didn't know it was part of a I think it overlap with some friendship
or allegiance to to Destiny.
>> But you don't just say he's cringe.
>> It's Yeah, they don't say he's cringe. >> I I
would I say cringe all the time. There are many times.
>> Yeah. I'm perfectly happy to call his son cringe. It's
the insane fearongering
uh grandstanding over, you know, someone who really in the grand
scheme of things is pretty inoffensive.
Yeah. Uh, fear-mongering
I would say
like somehow it goes beyond fear-mongering. There is like literally
actively a thing now where people are trying to launder their
own bad deeds and like wash the like actually launder the reputations
of people by just going like and by the way Assange shocked his
dog. I sorry not literally that but they will do like that. It's
like gone a step beyond what whatever existed before you know
the past year with Tecton and Nux and these people. It's like
there's there's a new evolution on it that I just like find it
particularly disturbing. It's rough. I think Hassan sees those
as totally connected. I see them as like one is downstream of
the other, but it's not like even an intention. In fact, they
might even prefer like people who really dislike Hassan might
even prefer that like Techone and Nucks and weren't doing that
like or the more Pegasus videos that are just like consistently
hitting like they do sort of they do sort of give fodder for
people on the other side of that
My god, are we doing the discourse now?
>> That transcends far beyond his own uh
>> Oh, it looks like uh Lerbox's chat is engaging in some
some rumor mongering about me,
man.
Man, >> growth and his own personal club. >> Uh many
of those guys don't want to >> I thought that was like
totally up to like allow people to do that. I thought that was
like a really up thing. >> [__] do work. And
they realize that like uh making Hassan derangement syndrome
style commentary is >> don't we like blame people for their
chats guys? Don't we like blame people for their chats? >> Stop
the snark. Stop the snark. >> Going to get going to secure
them at least like 200,000 likes or I mean 200,000 views on YouTube
and it's the easiest place to go to is like the subreddits that
he occupies. The subreddit is his community brigades aggressively.
You're everything he thought he could be and he'll never forgive
you for being that. Yes.
>> Overlap with Nazis too. Very very liberal as audience.
They they have no base values at all, which is precisely the
reason why they will cooperate with anyone and everyone. >> Great
pleasure. >> Oh, this is members only content. I can't
watch it because I'm not a member and I'm not going to leak the
members only content. >> That No, I'm I'm literally laughing
at the fact that a whole bunch of these people will go on Pisco
super hard. Not Loerbox, but a whole bunch of people will go
on Pisco hard because there's snarkers in his chat who are lying
about somebody that they think is very important. Okay. Now,
for me personally, I I see some stuff happening in load boxes
chat that I'm like very annoyed about. Okay, you will watch.
Not actually. It's just chatters and also the chatter who's defending
me is obviously correct. Watch the globicular video when it's
released for everyone uh with Adam. Is the debate styles to come
at you with all the stats and facts is easily defeated by not
using any facts or stats. Just hit him with a n bro. You're lying.
Dude sucks. Wait, what? He doesn't actually approach the subject
matter with like a full assessment of all the facts. He just
cherrypicks data points and then mass-produces them. Gish galloping.
Uh, he goes to Wikipedia pages and tries to craft the the most
successful, most reliable narrative. Yes, cool. Adam interviewed
Clvicular and Mogd's ass.
>> What's good? What are you doing here? >> That
was just a very surreal tangent from the
>> That was a very, very surreal tangent from the Live
and Learn. [laughter] What the What did I just watch? >> JTO
is a subhuman antivan loser with DG remorse syndrome. Well, that
last part is absolutely true. I do very much regret my time there.
Can't imagine people who don't. I just am I crazy? I can't imagine
people who don't regret their time there. I just I can't imagine
being in the mind of those people at all. Like, hey, I totally
believed in this guy who is a lying degenerate fs slur who couldn't
who couldn't like prevent himself from violating the consent
of the people he cared about most. You should have held dearest.
I Yeah, I don't like that. I hate that aspect of myself. Feels
like that's pretty normal. No, I I feel like how could you not
be that? By the way, the people who are saying these things in
Litterbox's chat, I would love to know. Okay, I would just love
to know. Hey, this Benju stink guy, what do you think about Pixie?
Just curious. What do you think about Pixie? I wonder what kind
of attitudes this guy, if I asked this guy, is Pixie a good person?
What do you think he'd have to say? What do you What do you think
he'd have to say? That's fine. That's fine. >> Gosh, I'm
not going to lie, man. I'm pretty tuned out from the whole Destiny
story with everything that's going on there. I think I the last
thing I heard >> uh he calls Pixie a gold digging who at
people only for clout. Basically referring to your relationship.
Just in case you just in case you react to this and want to know,
he consistently harasses and tries to destroy the life of Pixie
and anybody around her. Just if you've been tuned out, just in
case you were tuned out, that's basically where it's going. I
can't imagine you're tuned out, but just in case you are tuned
out, that's where it is. is that the
the Rose person that he thought he was texting was actually a
dude who was abusing her or some uh type. It's been a while since
I've had people uh nagging me about it, though. That's nice.
I can't wait for your manifesto, dude. I don't have a manifesto.
What are you talking about? I even >> Spider in chat trying
to say he doesn't say type. I I mean, we're dealing with pretty
big liars here, but Spider's in the chat saying he doesn't say
type
>> because the judge is chilling and doesn't ruin anything.
Interesting.
I mean, every now and then I get people who come to me. Might
as well just say something. Why not? I'm bored. Um,
>> every now and then I'll get people being like, "Hey,
Lord, are you ready to apologize to Destiny now to get now that
everything's fallen to pieces into court documents?" And I'm
like, "Okay." Um,
so my one,
if I had to distill like my decision to, you know, do what I
did or take the position I did, it's kind of just down to like
one thing. Like what what is the position now? Cuz I I remember
back then there was all these arguments about implied consent
and all this stuff and like did she or did she not share videos
with her ex or whatever? Like I mean I I knew what I'd been told
about all that stuff at the time and it seemed like not the greatest
alibi. But is the position now that like when people talk about
implied consent, the idea is is that like like say you're a couple
and you're
kind of like you're in bed and you're both kind of snoozing and
then like the guy starts the girl and like uh and it's like they're
both kind of okay with that like without asking, you know, like
they're just it's not like he has to like imply consent is that
like the thought of sitting there and going, "Hey, do you want
to
>> I
there's like a good argument here. The thing he's going to try
to argue is basically like you're saying you she was so comfortable
with something that
okay, she's so comfortable with something that she just allowed
it. So now that can't possibly apply to somebody that Dusty didn't
know well enough to know it was a guy catfishing him. Totally
eviscerated that argument. Even again, even though that argument
was already dead on the ground, it's totally eviscerated a second
time by the fact that he was catfished. Okay,
it's also come out since that he only knew the person for a week
before he sent the Pixie video. That's what Lot's going to try
to say here. I don't know. I don't know why
I don't know why
Loader started with this one or started with this. I feel like
there's a way less I don't know >> right now. It's like
you know the answer is going to be yes cuz you're both like cuddling
and grinding or whatever the else Okay. Uh but I don't know what
the argument is with the with the Rose thing. Is the argument
that like
are we are we to are we believing now that if Steven had asked
Pixie, hey, I'm texting this person I met online. She I think
she's over she says she's over 18, 19, I don't know. Uh can I
like send her one of our videos? >> Met her a week ago.
>> And are we to assume the answer would have been Yeah.
Go ahead.
>> Is that what the argument is? Is that >> Yeah.
Yeah. Because Pixie is like a degenerate who totally wants to
anybody will let anybody do anything to dig. She's going to think
she Supreme is old guy. She old guy Supreme. She's a Yeah, >> that's
like the argument. By the way, neither of us believe that. Neither
of us are that judgmental. Okay. Quimman loved Sugar and Spice.
Quan was the the largest patron of Sugar and Spice. Okay. He
was oiling that show behind the scenes. You don't even know >> that
with the implied consent. Like based on the circumstances, if
he had asked, she would have said yes.
That's that's the bit that I'm just kind of finding impossible
to believe. But I don't know if the >> I mean technically
the way he's going to get corrected there is no. It means that
it wouldn't have been it would have been reasonable regardless
of what she would have said, right? It would have been reasonable
for him to
like assume that she'd say yes.
Now those are essentially the same thing, but they're not quite
people >> has answered that question or
>> if the lore masters have anything in
but [__] Hello spider.
>> So it didn't work. What the [__] >> What?
Your vine boom? >> Yeah, it did.
>> Um, does it snow in Scotland? >> Does it snow
in Scotland?
>> Yeah, of course it was in Scotland.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We got Kinda and
The dream team is assembling. Let's go. >> Wow. The whole
the whole group home here. Let's go. >> North and most
of Canada or at least the populated parts.
>> Well, little bro, I'm from Cali. Okay. Southern Cali.
Little bro, >> why would living in Cali tell your opinion
on whether or not it snows in
>> Because I'm live in Scotland. Do they have sun in Cali?
>> I don't know. I live in Scotland. I haven't seen the
sun in 40 days. What?
>> You know, you know what? >> Maybe that's the same
in Cali, bro. >> I'll never get over that one guy who I
think is a lumber box guy, the Hussein guy who came in my Discord
was like, I don't even like Destiny. I don't even like Destiny.
And now he like uses the food shops Discord tag and is like all
over the food shops community. Like, did he wait until the uh
this guy was so annoying in my Discord, too? He's like, "I'm
not even a DJ. I don't even like DG." Well, sorry, he didn't
say that. He was like, "I don't even support any of this stuff."
And basically, yeah, now using the No, the Hussein guy. That
Hussein guy was crazy. I just I'm like,
how did he wait until the thing reared its head to go and be
like, I'm going to support food shops. Solidarity with food shops.
I these people baffle me. Okay. I also know way too much. I I
can't help it. Okay. I can't help it. I see a screenshot of something
and I like notice I connect to things and it just bothers me.
So, I just had to get it out on stream. Okay. >> Cuz why
you think Okay. If a non-American ask is very sunny, >> does
it snow? Does it snow in Scotland? You probably like, >> "Oh,
oh yeah. It does snow, man." >> Nero too. Uh Nero was Iraqi.
He was always a If you didn't know, Nero was a from the very
beginning. You just weren't paying attention.
Nero literally only talk. Nero sounds like Turkey Tom to tell
you the truth. >> I just love how these women are really
small and tiny and petite. Yeah,
>> I'm sorry. Nero was a from the beginning. If you're
shocked about anything that happened with him, you're not paying
attention.
>> Like a misogynist.
I'm going to add the Arab tint in there and just go full on.
But like he was always going to like DG is literally his spiritual
home.
That's not even close.
>> You know, he was in the
the professional viewing. He was posting
>> 12-year-old Natie Portman.
>> Almost certainly. Yeah. >> No longer calls loner
boner box, does he
>> Why not? >> He does a little bit here.
>> Who came up with that anyway, I wonder.
>> Boner Box. >> How long has that been a nickname
for you? I feel like it's been forever. I'm pretty sure my friends
have said that about me before I even had any viewers. Like when
I had my channel and only and each video had like 100 views.
I'm pretty sure one of my friends called me
>> It's just that whatever.
>> it ain't nothing. >> Did you ever explain where
the name lumber box came from? >> Yeah, all the time. I've
given at least 10 different explanations.
>> What do you guys here talk about? >> Different
explanations. >> Sorry, just I was just having a very
>> Dude, I swear to God, I can just feel Queen seething
at these questions like spiritually through the Nether. Or I
could just like feel this. >> I'm fine. Wow. I'm I'm >> Hey.
Hey Quimman. How'd you pick the name Queman?
>> Hey Quan, you ever think about like this thing? Hey
Quan, what's the weather like there, man? >> Serious conversation
in the chat. You guys are talking about snow and like
>> Oh, I mean I actually I was going to
>> maybe I should just DM you about it. I was going to
come in here and and um explain stuff about the core case because
I've been following it, but >> um do you have to Yeah.
Litterbox, let Kinda come in here and explain stuff about the
court case. I actually would love if I could get an update on
the court case from Kinda. I would love
>> I can't I don't understand this. Okay. I point out if
there's someone around me that is like clearly disabled, I point
it out. I say I will not be seen as like someone who is blind
to the fact that there are obviously people around me. you know,
if there's someone that is obviously
legitimately,
you have to point out, but so regularly now, I will see genuinely
disabled people just accepted into the fold by, you know, a lot
of different places. It's not just Kinda. It's like this guy
called Young Bob in the UK who's like a right-wing influencer
and he's like a visibly disabled child. He's like 17.
>> Yeah. [clears throat] >> They're all big him up
now. He's like the the number one restore guy. I just don't understand
how people do it. It makes you look so terrible just hanging
around with actual >> I watched that Restore UK video or
whatever that new one that everybody's watched. I I saw somebody
watch that.
you would have to be to be you would have to be >> It's
literally so cool. Let's just go split the reform though. It's
awesome.
It's that that ad couldn't have been made more perfectly if it
was like cast by the director of the boys and like shot and written
by the >> know about HR culture and all this [__]
>> Yeah, it's just like >> the question that I as
Shark man. >> Uh I mean I do kind of but I don't know if
it's something that I've >> Bro, also Asmin Gold's reaction.
Did you watch Asmin Gold's reaction to it?
>> Uh I watched the clip of Asan talking about I didn't
watch Asold's full reaction. Asmin Gold's reaction was very
>> I heard that he invited Robert Low on his stream. I
think that sounds really cool. I think he should do that. >> Asminold
basically off to that advertisement and it was so funny to me.
We're going to we're going to enable domestic investment and
invest in OUR PEOPLE. YEAH. STOP stop investing in
stop investing in inbred from other countries. Give that money
to your people. It's just so funny. inbred migrants. It's dude,
it's it's good stuff. I might pull it up after this. It was very
funny. I just watched it myself. Or maybe I watched it when I
was watching Motorbox this morning or something. I I can't remember.
someone's freaking out about right now is because uh there's
like some push to like outlaw cousin marriage and
you know stop the NHS from
putting out guidance on dealing with you know pregnancies between
cousins and [__] like that because they're like obviously
the argument on one side is like well it doesn't actually stop
the cousin marriages from happening. All it does is stigmatize
and stop access to resources and make people's lives worse. And
the other side like >> this argument. >> No, you're
you're making it so the Muslims are their cousins,
>> I guess, is what they think happens.
>> I see. >> So that so it has to be has to all be
banned
and uh there can be no help
>> Wow. I don't know. That's very interesting. Your your
countries I I can personally say for my country, we don't have
a lot of politics around it to be
Give it a couple years. >> Doesn't happen. Just doesn't
happen. So, >> give it a couple years, bro.
>> I I think there are just too many Indians for like to
really be a problem there, right?
>> And we're trying to duplicate. >> Is it really
Is it really all just about
population density? I understand more common in rural areas and
[__]
>> I I literally don't know.
>> I actually think Indians do cousin marriages. So, I
actually don't I actually don't know. I was going to say I feel
like it's more culturalist about like uh >> I feel like
arranged marriages go between cousins or second cousins. I feel
like that happens. But anyway, I guys, we got to be very careful,
okay?
we're we're stomping over and I don't want to ruin this the segment,
okay? It's Kinda and Spider content time. Okay, Queen came in
and said people he he had a rant about people who are visibly
disabled or audibly disabled. And I don't know what that has
to do with the content currently on screen, but I did like the
rant. We did eventually get to get into the the restore UK stuff.
So >> really want that. Like I don't know if you actually
want to talk about it. Like I'll just DM you. >> Okay.
[laughter] I mean, I don't know what you're referring to. So
use your
>> What? Oh, my wits. No, I mean
like I trust I trust you to thinking that it's better to DM her.
Yeah. Don't worry. >> Yeah, I think I rather would because
it's just going to get into a bunch of personal about Pixie.
>> Okay. I don't know if you want to drag that out like
Yeah. >> Okay, then.
>> I'll just point out she came here and put him on the
spot about it. >> So, not enough wits to not do that
>> So, when I was like, "Oh, yeah. This is all crazy about
Pixie, by the way. He just totally on Pixie all the time now.
That's what he spends all of his time doing." And I was like,
"Oh, there's no way Loner Box is not aware." Well, now I know.
I've been guaranteed by Kinda. Thank you, Kinda, that Lonerbox
is not going to be unaware. Thank you, Kinda. Very good job,
Kinda. We We love Kinda here, don't we, folks? We love We love
>> Anyh who any
>> Oh, the fundraiser is going really well. You guys are
awesome. And so so is DGG because I went on there yesterday and
advertised it and yeah, people are uh I think we're we're up
to quite a bit. It's like to over 2K now. So that's
Huh.
Just Kinda coming in to absolutely nuke this guy from orbit.
You know what,
Quayman? Apologize to Kinda now. Right >> Apologize to
Kinda right now. >> For what?
>> How does this not just prove everything I said?
[laughter] >> Because I'm going to assume intention cuz
it's just unbelievable. Okay.
>> Yeah. Love went about too like days ago. He was like,
"Yeah, sure." Um,
pretty much
that [__] >> just massive. I don't I don't
want anything to do with Destiny. I don't I don't think this
guy's good. He's kind of a piece of Massive shout out to DG on
the Lord Box stream, guys. Thank you DG for helping us with our
fundraising.
>> What's the fundraiser for?
>> I don't know.
>> Mobility scooter or >> Come on,
It's a Bonics lessons for Spider. Okay. G, be serious.
>> Wait. Phonics lessons. [laughter] Phonics lessons. He
doesn't need a Bonnics lessons. He's already black belt in that.
My bad. My bad. My bad. My bad. Phonics. Phonics lessons. Yes.
>> That's language. >> I said I what?
>> Go to Ukraine. >> I go to Ukraine. No, I don't.
>> You're going I mean >> Oh, would you? Would you?
>> I kind of want to. >> But if I if I give you 10k
right now. If I give you 10k right now, would you go
>> Yeah. 10. >> Yeah, I'll go for Yeah, I'll go for
10k.
Spider, you don't have 10K. >> This is more like I I mean
that in like an insurance sense. Wait, I think it was alleged
in court that Hang on. Shut the [__] up. There's
a I don't know why I'm talking about this. I want to open this.
>> Yeah, don't I'll I'll talk. >> Uh it was alleged
that Pixie shared videos of her with Destiny without Destiny's
consent. Loner box just in case he reacts to this. Okay. Basically,
Destiny went, "No, you
sick legal." >> I'll talk to you about it in private later.
It's not worth it. >> No, no, wait. If this is something
I've already spoken about, um, is this because Hang on.
>> I don't actually
No, it's fine. Um, let me find that chat. What did that say?
No, this is an old claim though, isn't it? >> He's been
doing this one on and off for a while. >> I mean, they
they deposed Pixie's ex, but I don't know if anything came out
of that. At least there's nothing that I've heard that came out
of that apart from like clarifications about timelines and
I believe there's explicit clarification that he consented to
Pixie sharing the video of him with Destiny obviously and Lot
Box knows that from like he knows that in private as well which
he said.
>> So Lot's entire stream is just DG joining his chat to
say Destiny didn't rip. Nope. I believe if uh I believe if they
were doing that in his chat, if they were going through his chat
and like consistently supporting Destiny, they would get banned
because there are some Lun Box mods that do actually dislike
Destiny still. But it is a lot of people who do like Destiny.
Uh and and want to be covert about it for some reason in like
the weirdest
Uh like I would say that the black cat person is somebody who
like go to that
I'm just saying it's like and
it is what it is, man.
>> Is this to do with No, this this was this was a claim
that was made really early on, wasn't it? This isn't that's not
new because he was saying um is this
because Pixie was sharing videos that she made with her ex to
with Steven. Is that the whole thing? And because she was doing
that and we don't know if her ex gave consent because that's
a that's a argument, right? >> Yes. Stephen alleged that
he did it. Well, yeah. No, I I agree. I think that you still
give it >> alleged with no basis obviously >> the
best like you know um thing or whatever but yeah >> like
if I'm dating Sally and Sally's like if I'm dating Sally and
Sally's like hey here's a video I made with my boyfriend Harry
I don't get to be like well you didn't tell me that whether or
not Harry consented to that video being given to me which means
you're probably fine with me as a public figure just kind of
just kind of popping away to this random person I just recently
met online
as that was that can't be it though that can't be the I I don't
trust people. >> No, it's not. >> Okay. That's not
>> No, I I mean, if you want, I can just say it, but >> No,
you're just saying.
that's not that's not talking about Ukraine, but it's actually
just >> Do we can we just
This is like super awkward already. >> Oh, if if you want
to talk Let's talk about Ukraine. Apparently, uh Ukraine has
regained 200 km of land because of the Russia Starlink outage.
they swooped in and took advantage. But it's actually not as
big of a deal as we all thought because that it turns out that
Russia's gains are actually just kind of a mirage because it
was like they managed to get one guy to like advance forward
through a gap in the line and then like he was just hanging out
in a house and then Russia was like we took all this territory
but it wasn't real and Russia and Ukraine actually just pushed
forward and like cleared out those dudes but because the front
line is inherently very porous and there's lots of holes in it
cuz neither side has enough guys to actually like you know um
have a solid have solid fortifications along the entirety of
the line. >> Well, it's [__] I'm glad this
was giving geopolitics analysis. I trust all of this.
I'm actually just taking this. >> That sounds like something
everybody would, you know, just throw on charts and stuff, right?
They'd never do any due diligence or anything to make sure that
Russia's actually >> there's two. It's just like one guy
there. It's like one guy. >> It's just one guy. And like
nobody from Ukraine bothered to dispute it cuz they were like,
"Yeah, that one guy's there. Technically, our line's 200 km further
into Ukraine." >> And like like who really cares? need
to go over there and check cuz it's like no benefit to us like
knowing where the >> where their captured lines are. So
>> nothing nothing.
>> What's your story? >> All the like footage that
Well,
uh my story is that we we have reached 4K theor
which is crazy to me. >> Oh jeez. I thought it was 2K.
That's
>> Yeah, that went really fast. It went like in a matter
of like 10 minutes. Yeah. From two to 4K.
>> Like a day on, right?
>> So, yeah. >> Lbox, have you thought about how
much DGG does for us over here? Have you thought about that?
Loader box, have you thought Have you thought about how great
that community is?
can I tell you about how Pixie how how your ex is like a lying?
Loader box, real quick, Lo Box, please. Quick court case update
on your stream.
We're going to be able to help a whole lot of people. >> Not
dumb. >> I really quiet. So,
>> I should get a bar. You >> seem all right. >> [__]
it. Does anyone know how to make a bar from that? Not have to
be. >> So, this must be something to do with um Ukraine
and Ukraine.
Okay. Somebody
uh somebody asked me if I wanted to support the lonerbox community
and their fundraising for Ukraine. And I
politely declined. Okay.
They're like, "Hey, do you want to announce this thing on your
stream?" And I was like, "No." I >> Ukrainian scammer.
Ukrainian [laughter]
>> Why is the Why is that battery?
>> If if Pixie won't give us Listen, if we're going to
call for Pixie's, you know, receipts for her um her legal case,
then I think we can use receipts for Ukrainian Anna, right? I
think that's only fair. All fair and love in >> And I think
Ukraine's at war technically, so got to be fair by definition,
really. >> Or is it from that website, wouldn't you? Yeah.
[groaning] >> Oh, yeah. I don't know if Streamlabs lets
you do that. >> Yeah, I don't think you can make um like
an active poll with that. So,
>> I mean, I'm guessing that most of the donations actually
came from DG.
>> bro, is this is this Loader Box's stream now? They just
come in and they're like talking about Destiny while he just
plays World War have so much money. They give us so much money
on his own [__]
They they've all got tech jobs within the last 3 years. >> I
listen I would never ever argue that Lunarbox got by Destiny
cuz that's just a lie. Okay. But this is absolutely like this
is him in the chair on his own stream having to hear about how
great DG is and how much they support him.
This is rough, dude. This is just rough. I I'm sorry, man. It's
tough. [__] [clears throat] tiny [__]
me. That's one
little [__] out of me. Listen,
this is kind of what you were talking about yesterday when you
covered the lyrics stuff, right? How like how do you get new
people on the fly? How do you get like somebody you could trust?
It's like those people are irreplaceable. They're like priceless.
The people you trust who can like anticipate your thoughts and
>> This is what happens when you don't have anybody like
that. It's just like
there are I I can't imagine I just I can't see some people. Mariti
seems switched on to
>> Yeah, she does. She does. I I like
Uh love Maruti. Okay. But I'm just saying that like these people
are coming on his stream and like actually doing this right now
and I'm just like kind of >> It's not he's got like nobody.
It's not like he's not got any, you know. >> But I think
he I think these people are like his guys as well.
>> Yeah. Sure, sure, sure. I I agree on Maritzi. I'm sure
there's like one or two other people too, but I'm just I'm just
saying it's rough, man. This is rough. I >> Yeah. And Spider
is not It's not his best. It's not his best. >> It's not
his best. I agree with you.
Okay. We are We are small, but we are proud of you guys also
donated like the very beginning especially. >> Yeah. There's
there's overlap. >> This is still this is still a loner
community fundraiser. So >> yeah, it's um you know for
Ukraine and everything. Um >> I mean is it if they raise
like 5% of the money or 10% of the is it really a loner community?
Also, those loner community fundraisers,
they donate money anywhere else.
>> Yeah, thank you.
>> Yeah, thanks guys. There's lots of DJers in here anyway.
Or at least like you know the ones who are not watching. Yeah,
like when Lunar is live, I usually watch him over Destiny. So
>> yeah, that's why you [laughter]
>> dude. When Lunar is live, I usually watch him over Destiny.
Oh my god. I would I'd actually shoot this person. I'd just be
like, "Get the out." Like, I might not be able to maintain the
composure. If somebody did this to me on my stream, I might not
be able to maintain the composure to not have like a Hassan level
crash out about it.
That's
crazy, dude.
Uh, car crash sound effect. Yeah, it's it's rough, man. >> Yeah.
Thanks, guys. There's lots of DJers in here anyway. Or at least
like you know the ones who are not like watching. Yeah, like
when Lunar is live, I usually watch him over Destiny. So >> yeah,
that's why I was here.
>> I'm sure that there's not one of the people I kind of
I don't like you. Go away. Get out of here. What's this? [laughter]
We need more loyalty. Okay, maybe there is a thing like less
is more. You know, like Xin Ping purging. He had six generals
in that office and now he's only got one. Maybe it's better that
way. He knows something. He's he stayed in power for a long time.
>> Maybe I should uh get on it. >> It's his one dude.
>> It's probably like four side general.
I can say verifiably Motorbox has at least four generals I'm
looking at with Maruti added in here. He would be better off
with one. I can say that
Hard to deny. >> Well, yeah. I think it's like it's his
>> I say that as somebody who loves Spider, by the way.
Spider is my boy. Okay. I love Spider. Okay. >> Second
in command guy or whatever. I think I do think that's very funny.
Also, did you guys see what I posted in stream suggestions? The
son is just going ridiculously crazy with that Chinese cosplay
>> and stream.
I was there. >> Where is it? >> Yeah, forgive me
for taking a picture of my screen because my screen uh um screenshot
program isn't working. >> This is this is just the guy
who has his finger on the pulse of what is needed for the Democratic
party to speak to the average person. You know, the voice of
the voiceless.
>> He's such a larer.
Like
I think I feel like his his glasses even even look like like
he he deliberately picked glasses that looked like that so he
could like I I don't know. It reminds me of um I I swear I've
seen some Chinese communist leader wear like thick black rimmed
glasses like that. It might have I don't know if it was ever
if it was Mau or not, but >> the exact glasses he always
wears. >> Yeah, it he's really he's really going for that
[__] It's very cringe. Also, I bet that outfit was
insanely expensive.
The M outfit was awesome and they're
don't I can't imagine I if his son's not dressed in like funny
like
>> M stream awards outfit. He had like this whole like
uh >> that was pretty funny. >> I didn't even know
that was a M outfit.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no. You're not watching. You're
not watching. There's a screenshot [laughter] >> like I
I don't know. You're >> reminds me of um I swear I've seen
some if it was
>> right here. Right here. I don't know if you could pull
it up. >> Oh yeah. He's got like a Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
funny as well. That's funny as well. That's awesome. Connor boy.
That's what Connor Boy did. >> I think that's like an explicit
costume. By the way, the other outfit was like you didn't know.
It was like lowkey, but this one's just an explicit >> I
mean it wasn't really low key, but yeah, it's it wasn't like
an explicit costume. low key for somebody who doesn't know anything
about Chinese communism at all. Like I I I
never seen a picture of Ma and you've never you've never seen
the picture. I just don't connect them in my head. You know what
I mean? Like somebody had to point out and I can go, "Oh yeah,
that is that outfit, isn't it?" But I would never have like looked
at that and gone, "Oh, that's obviously Ma's outfit right there."
But maybe it's something I don't do. >> Screenshot program.
Like he he deliberately picked glasses that looked like that
so he could like I I don't know. It reminds me of um I I swear
I've seen some Chinese communist leader wear like thick black
rimmed glasses like that. It might have I don't know if it was
ever if it was Mao or not, but yeah, it he's really he's really
going for that. Wait, hold on. Okay,
who's the guy? Dang Xiaoing. This isn't the guy who wore these
glasses, is it? I feel like I've seen a picture of Deng in the
thick rim glasses and that would be so funny if it were him.
But maybe I'm hallucinating because if that if that was if that
was Deng who did that, the guy who I believe is the um right
cuz that's the guy who was the like fascist guy who went and
founded Taiwan, right?
Am I crazy? Oh no, no, he's PRC. No, he's PRC. Never mind, dude.
I I'm telling you guys, I don't know anything about Chinese history.
>> Dang did a bunch of um technological advancement thing,
right? some infrastructure and technology I think. >> I'm
trying to think of who the guy is who did the >> one after
Mau I think. >> Yeah, he's the one >> the Kaishek
is
>> Kaishek is who I'm thinking of.
>> Can't remember what the thing about Dang is there. There's
some with like Dangism and there's like I don't like five tenants
of it or some or five points that improved on some like that.
I can't remember. I remember reading about like years ago. >> But
I do think it's probably him that had the glasses. I feel like
I've seen him in those glasses, those goofy ass
like the thick rim glasses or some [__] >> Yeah,
it's very cringe. Also, I bet that outfit was insanely expensive.
>> Yeah, it definitely belongs in the wank tax category.
>> Were you here when I was talking about the Wang tax?
Yeah. >> Yes. Yes, I was. >> I think more people
should get sold. I don't know why the >> I'll be honest.
I'll be honest, guys. I don't want to I don't want to say this,
but sometimes I'm like
sometimes I'm like, "Man, I wish my audience would try to be
a little bit better sometimes, just in a general sense." Sometimes
I think that sometimes I'm like arguing with someone, I'm like,
"Man, you should be better." And then I feel like Loner Box has
cured me of all of that. You guys are actually awesome.
Lo just totally fixed all of my concerns about my audience for
me like instantly. Like just overnight, I watch this stream and
I'm just like, "Huh? Wait, it could be so much worse. It could
actually be infinitely worse. >> No one does it. Like,
how could anyone oppose it? Well, I mean, how >> sometimes
like uh Spruce Willis, like every time Straight Ray joins, Spruce
Willis and she cams up, Spruce Willis immediately comments on
her and gets timed out. And I'm like, dude, you got to be better.
And now I'm like, man, it could be so much worse. It could actually
be it could actually be so much >> How would you realistically
implement that? I mean, you'd have to um >> Well, people
use people use consumer indexes like when people talk about uh
real income, right? That's not just like
>> Okay, buddy. Lol. Come on,
Bruce Willis.
Disagree with what I said or don't complain. You you either disagree
or complain about it. Okay. >> I said for the price of
everything in the economy, they pick like a certain list of consumer
items. There's like a isn't there like a like an index of consumer
goods that people are expected to buy generally? Isn't that what
that how to do that or am I completely off?
Is it called the consumer price index
>> Yes, there's there's a thing called the consumer price
index. >> No, no, no. You see me?
>> No. We
>> uh Queen, you done any Dioro? You looked at any of the
Dioro snark from today? Look at his little following
any uh Oh, I did see that on my timeline briefly. Yeah. Saw like
Bolex was making fun of him for being fat or something. >> Being
fat. He posted just a horrifying picture. That's very unfortunate
picture, man. That's unlucky dog.
Let me see. I'm going to check your farms for it if I want to
find this link cuz I I saw it, but I don't remember the context
I saw it in. And definitely we posted your Discord, right?
>> Is it not? Oh my god. What
is this guy's audience doing?
Oh. Uh, don't worry. Kathy got me. If nobody else got me, Kathy
got me. Every time I said something bad about Nicholas, he's
like, "Oh, here it is. Here it is. This is the picture, dude.
>> That's disgusting. >> He He looks like an old
lady somehow. >> Disgusting. That's actually disgusting,
>> He looks like a really old lady somehow.
[laughter] That's so weird.
Block posted this just to [__] with him, by the way.
Like, like I think Bo said he looks like an Amber Alert or something.
Maybe there's in response.
It's uh it's brutal, dude. It's brutal. Yeah, I think Nick said
something about Bolex looking like an Amber Alert and then Bo
said that you need Amber Alerts for the earthquakes she caused
or some and posted pictures of that. >> That was rough,
dude. It was rough. >> Just uh just back and forth picture.
>> Hold on. Where's There you are. Okay. So, it's uh it's
rough. I'll go over that in a little bit. Okay, we got to finish
we just got to finish off this uh brain trust meeting over here
and then we will be >> the wank tax refers to taxing specific
products that only wankers would buy. So like crazy expensive
yachts, the kind of insane over $100.
No, no, no. [laughter] It's he means it in a very British
>> I don't think there's anything more in that lunar box
vod. I think you're failing to understand just how much like
peace and and tranquility watching these people talk on Motorbox's
stream provides me. Kathy, I think you failed to understand.
Okay. I I just enjoy watching this. All right.
>> Or Scotty. Yeah, I should say British. I don't know.
People say that. >> Why does he run a group home, bro?
I don't get it. Well, who would want to do >> I Yeah, it's
reference items. Yeah. So, just make one of those. But for the
wank tucks, just categorize all the wank items and it's not going
to be difficult. If there's any gray areas, just take it off.
Okay. Hey, I'm a nice guy. If you're not sure if it's a wank,
it's probably not a wank I am. But no one's going to be debating
over whether or not designer ice cubes that cost $300 for a pack
is not worthy of a wank. >> I can't believe that exists.
I was very surprised.
Even though I shouldn't be.
>> Wank tax. Is that >> Yes. Wait, are you googling
it? Don't Google it. Spider is real, is it? >> No, it's
not. >> It's going to be a real thing, >> dude. Spider's
awesome. I love
It's the
people are always talking about people are always talking about
wealth taxes. People want to find ways to tax the wealthy in
a way that doesn't uh alienate average voters that because they
everyone's afraid that they're not going to get any. >> Wait.
Oh no. Oh, hold on. Wait. What am I making fun of here?
>> This is a stupid response to the wealth tax, by the
way. This is like absolutely what Landbox is saying here. If
he's actually suggesting this is a response to the wealth tax.
>> Oh, hold on. What is he saying? Well, he's saying like
people are No, it's about he's saying people want a wealth tax,
but you can't do a wealth tax because it alienates, you know,
whatever. Um, so do a tax on these super expensive designer items
only super rich people buy. So, yeah, you raise no revenue. Obviously,
part of the appealing part of of a wealth tax is that you're
able to collect such a huge amount of revenue from it, but you
wouldn't collect a huge amount of revenue from just taxing these
items super hard. You'd probably just disincentivize buying them
more than
Yeah, this is why I know people really hate it. Like progressives
really hate a value added tax. I just feel like a value added
tax just works really well. I I understand that it like it basically
I think the reason progressives hate it is because if you don't
do a tax return, you'll never get that money back, right? That's
why they hate it. So it's just like a tax on poors. But I
I super I don't know. You do like >> land value taxes are
good, too. Land value taxes, those are cool. Land value taxes
are okay, but there's like a density to land that you can get.
Like dude, the the like a data center is going to make so much
money versus what the land value is, and you're not going to
increase the value based on what the data center is like. Um
like I it won't be a linear one to one increase, right?
>> I don't think a land value tax is bad, but I think it
starts to miss out on on like the level >> you can get
you can I mean doesn't mean you can't have carveouts for like
certain businesses if you need a certain industry to expand.
>> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. The idea is that
you're taxing people's wealth that you can you can target wealth
pretty accurately by doing that
>> without a lot of people huge
>> Yeah. A lot of people hate the idea with like uh they
hate like um what is it like a if you did like a value added
tax with a
stipend like basically what Yang was talking about. I do think
that like kind of balances out. Some people don't like it because
then you need to be on the books with the government, but it's
like I'm sorry. Just get on the books with the government, man.
>> Probably about it. >> It's not. It's >> going
to be a real thing.
>> It's the
people of >> people are always talking about wealth taxes.
[laughter] People want to find ways to tax the wealthy in a way
that doesn't uh alienate average voters that because they everyone's
afraid that they're not going to get any that they're going to
get
pushed into the bracket. So what you do is but people do like
mansion taxes cuz it's very easy to distinguish like a 2 million
pound house from anything that's above or below. Um but most
of these wealth taxes don't work cuz it's difficult to estimate
like asset value and especially like uh things that fluctuate
quite a lot. So taxing that kind of thing is very difficult.
It's also very easy to hide that kind of stuff. So even legally.
So what people should do is we have VAT in the UK which is like
a what do you call >> Value added tax. >> Yeah. But
what do you call it in America? It's uh sales tax. >> Sales
tax. >> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. But there should be a sales tax,
like an extra sales tax for luxury items that are just cringe,
like yachts and speedboats and jet skis and
you know what I mean? And like solid gold chessboards and golden
toilets
and designer ice cubes [laughter] that cost $300 for a pack of
ice cubes and just take all those goods and just tax the [__]
out of them. Like you just have to pay wank tax on them and it
should be called wank tax. >> It will raise 20 pounds in
revenue
>> I mean it would have to be pretty small. It would have
to be like
>> the problem won't raise any money. That just like that
is the most obvious thing that like yeah that will raise like
no >> Well like if you do it on yachts it's like wouldn't
they just buy the yacht somewhere else and then how do you
get the tax on it? >> True. like they're not going to buy
like if they're rich enough to buy a yacht, they just could buy
it somewhere without the tax. >> I don't know.
>> To be honest, probably nobody is buying in Scotland
or in America or in England. Probably people aren't just buying
yachts, I would imagine, that are like produced there because
of the sales taxes. It already exists. >> And a special
treatment, if you're like a
there should also be if you're like a millionaire or above, there
should be audits of your wardrobe. They should make appraisals
and value all your clothing and find out if you've worn anything.
Like >> it was funny finding out that that's like pretty
much unironically what the IRS does. They literally go to your
Instagram or your kids Instagram and they're just like actually
we're just going to look at the kinds of [__] you
guys like talk about daily.
Oh, you you reported like 100,000 in income and you're talking
about going, you know, to this you're talking about going to
the SE shell for a vacation. Yeah. Audit. Audit immediately.
You You made $100,000 this year going to the seell. Yeah. No.
Audit immediately. Get this guy out of >> Like less than
five times in a year. >> Oh no. The secret BDSM drawer
>> because if you're going to spend like $200 on a pair
of shoes and you only wear them twice. Yeah, you should you should
pay like 100% tax rate on that.
insane. That's crazy. >> And the thing about this taxes
is that literally no everyone would enjoy doing it. All of the
workers who are going in doing the audits and the tax collectors,
they would love their job. Society would like it and even the
people who want to buy those luxury goods, they're they think
that if they they these are the kind of people that think if
the more expensive a product is, the better it is. So, you're
literally making it even better. So,
that
is just genuinely true. Maybe not for clothes necessarily, and
there's probably like some threshold,
but I'm sorry. I don't know.
I I feel like that's just true. Okay. >> So, they're going
to feel more validated because now their $350 pack of ice cubes
is going to cost $700 because of the wank tax and they're going
to think it's twice as good as it was before the wank tax. So,
everyone's happy. Am I wrong? >> China would love this
policy.
>> China would love this policy.
>> I won't. >> This is like a smug bug policy. That's
like a That's kind of who I am. >> Yeah. [laughter] >> But
it actually makes sense. It's like it's like a smug bug poly
made sense and we're actually enforcable.
I Dude, I've heard Smug Bug talk about what he wants in the world
a couple times. He sounds like he's usually pretty informed.
How did Smug Bug get this terrible >> re when he said um
like when he said that kids should be given so they can learn
about toys when they're when they're 12? >> Did he say
that? Not seen that one. >> Listen, smart guy most of the
time. Maybe he could convince me of that. I don't think so. But
if anybody could, I bet it's Smug Bug. Okay. I'd probably if
he just talked to me for long enough, I'd probably be begging
him to stop and [laughter] I'd just be like, "You win."
no. He always he seems like pretty smart when he argues for policies,
but maybe I just miss his like
I think he had something of a lark where people just started
calling him a all the time. I missed most of it other than the
one where he was like post
>> Yeah, sure. Well, >> lives that.
>> Okay, that's just his life. >> You're gonna >> That's
what they're gonna call his uh autobiography.
[laughter]
>> summoning him.
>> Kicking ass. >> Wait, summoning who? Sorry. Oh,
one sec. >> PS5 does not have a wink tax. PS5 Pro >> HW
Bush signed a luxury tax in 991. It didn't really work, unfortunately.
You first of all, I do not trust HW Bush to decide what is worthy
of the wank tax or not. Also, don't call it a luxury tax. The
luxuries are nice, okay? Like a spa is luxury, okay? Or like
nice dark. >> I get what he's saying as it is just going
to not work out. It's like one of those essentially when you
add like complicated things to the tax code, they just get evaded
super hard. >> Ice cream for breakfast ass policy.
>> Chocolate is luxury.
A good pillow is
>> not like a speed
boat. Okay, these are different things. Like like a jet ski,
you know, where those guys go to where guys go to Dubai and sit
in the jet ski and spin around in circles until they get bored.
>> You're just going to employ like Marie Condo to go into
their like closet to like search their closet. >> Yeah.
Be amazing. >> Clothing. Does this bring you joy?
>> She kind of she
>> Spider one again. Spider one again. Spider one [laughter]
again.
[gasps] Uh, wang tax. Uh, sounds.
[laughter] Thank you, Spider. >> I mean, like, what about
Would you pay extra for your mic though? The mic you use? Pretty
good, right? >> Did I pay extra for it? >> Like,
would you? >> What do you mean? >> If you got the
wink tax,
>> why would they put a wank tax on a
If it were like if it were like a if it were like one of those
vintage tube amps that are literally so degraded [laughter] that
they've lost all their top end but people still pay 10k on it
because they think that uh that they they think you know people
talk I don't have you heard musicians talk about that warm vintage
tone on like it's a thing that people doing >> uh every
so you say spider doesn't open his mouth all the way. Spider
imagine spider is like slowly fading away. He's like every single
statement he makes on stream he's like doing a like a fadeaway
jump shot. Okay. He's like slowly drifting away from his mic.
He has to say it pretty quickly and he has to like slowly get
quieter as he finishes saying
That [__] sounds kind of
I It's every single every single, you know, statement from Spy.
>> It's like he's like shuffling around. You know what
I mean? It's like he's like, you know, like like you can he's
like talking out one side of his mouth. He's like >> I
know exactly what he sees when he does it. Okay.
He sees like the wizzed old black janitor in like any sitcom
ever who just sort of like makes a little quip and then he like
walks on. That's who he thinks he is. Okay.
>> I don't know, man. That seems kind of dumb. And then
he just keeps like going along mopping the floor. >> Does
he real If that's actually how he thinks he seems,
does he realize that he just comes off disabled?
>> Tell me landed with him yet. >> Moping the floor.
Mama said there'll be days like this. [laughter] We have to >> I
went the whole segment without saying that. I went the whole
segment without referencing that so far. >> And then you
just >> It is difficult. It is difficult. >> They
talk about the warm vintage tone. That all that means is that
the the higher frequencies have literally just disappeared because
it's so because it's old. That's all it is. It's just they're
just describing wear and tear. Yeah. >> So yeah, that kind
of stuff. Absolutely. 100%. Or, you know, you can buy like guitar
leads that have gold plates in them because some people think
it's better if you pay more for the goldplated guitar leads.
>> You know what this reminds me of? I watched this YouTube
earlier today of an art collector
uh that has like really expensive art in his home and he said
like you know this piece this is a piece of wood that I collected
from the river for free and I just hung it up on my wall and
people come to my apartment ask me how much does this cost and
I tell them it's like 20 to 30k
[laughter] it's just like to like troll them like yeah >> yeah
I've heard people doing that kind of thing but if people are
doing that if people are also buying really expensive art. You
can maybe you can maybe get away with not getting taxed on that.
But
you have to you have to be able to write like three sentences
about why you like that art piece so much. >> Bro, you
are a communist. Okay, you are a commie bro. You're a commie.
You're a [__] commist. >> This is gig capitalism.
This is capitalism.
This is capitalism with taste. That's all it is. >> I'm
just trying to make capitalists better. Okay? Because capitalists
buy so much wank. Okay. It's a problem. It's
>> My shoes. >> My shoes. >> What's that? >> That's
a Vos rip. He just totally ripped a Vosch bit there. >> Maybe
I
had a whole thing where he was like just call just call socialism
super capitalism and right wingers will love >> Oh, I see.
Oh, man. Yeah. Sure, sure, sure. I've never I've never heard
that from Bosch. I've just listened to this whole thing. It's
like
I don't want to It's such lazy analysis, but is the entire thing
just like how could we tax this on for his stupid shirt?
Is that
like is that literally
all it is?
>> Dude. Yeah. Dude, it's the is the run in his son's pockets
tax. That's what it actually is. Let's be real. It's just it
literally looks like I hate I hate his Gucci shirt. I want run
his pockets.
I sw but like I swear to God I'm trying to I'm trying to think
of think of like another thing that's going on here and it just
seems like that a little bit. >> are not wink. Okay, they're
pretty even though I don't wear them all the time. >> You're
probably what's what are your shoes? Describe your shoes to me.
>> I got I got Air Force I got like Jordan ones. I got
like uh Nike Dunks.
>> I don't know what that means. What's your most expensive
pair of shoes? Those are not expensive shoes.
>> That's not wine taxi. [__] How often do
you wear them?
probably like
every
once a month.
>> Maybe. Maybe. No, but [laughter] but that would be more
like the wardrobe audit. That's like a separate policy. That's
only for people who are like >> Yeah. Uh Lower Box just
prescribed the most racist tax of all time. You do have to put
a income floor in there cuz black people be having like a random
thousand set of sneakers when that's not they live [laughter]
in.
>> Tweet tax. Yes. Dude, there was this there was this
crazy trade unionist like 10 years ago. I saw him do this interview.
He was like a trade unions guy communist. >> He was saying
that one of his ideas would be [laughter] >> man you like
a communist or something. You communist type [__]
bro.
>> To get the state to charge a penny per email. Then people
have to pay one p for every email they send. I'm like, wait,
what about a penny a tweet for social media posts? that if you're
going to disservice society with your spam then or and that would
deal with the bots, wouldn't it? If you tax tweets,
what's the people would choose their words carefully,
I guess you're right
cuz like you don't want to like overload the server, right? >> I
just think there are a lot of things in society that uh that
should be taxed. Yeah. I don't know why they don't >> make
sure the internet is as expensive as possible so we don't have
to like [__] read [__]
>> absolute takes on the internet.
>> Yeah. And they're these are all win-win as well, right?
It's all win-win.
>> You are a communist, bro.
You're you're basically a zombies
and economists by the way.